foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen today is
day one of the World's Cup finals and of
course we have bianchist of Duda facing
off against Sergey kariagin and Magnus
Carlson is still in the tournament but
he has been relegated to the third place
matchup with Vladimir feta save it's
going to be an incredibly exciting
finals match and it's going to be a very
exciting third place match I'm GM Daniel
nareditskien once again it is a pleasure
to be bringing you today's commentary
with former women's world champion
Grandmaster how are you fun uh if on
it's going to be a pretty exciting day
uh what are your preliminary thoughts
yesterday was just crazy
hi Daniel yeah I wasn't like
a heartbreak finish I wouldn't really
get back to uh to the let's say so the
normal life thought oh it's finished
because everything happened almost in
the last seconds I mean it's normal in
some faster uh faster chance like rapper
or even bullets but what happens in the
world cup is actually the size and match
that you know somehow gives it a like
more colors on it and of course today
we're going to have let's say uh two
very interesting matches uh I was just
thinking you know before the time like
whether Magnus and Sergey will face each
other again in the final novel okay they
didn't play with each other
yeah I mean that would have been that
would have been a crazy uh Grudge Match
of course after the world championship
match but it is not meant to be but
still got to save Carlson I'm looking
forward to that match as well uh let's
take a quick look at the format now the
one important thing to note is that in
contrast to previous years
uh this is the two game match so it used
to be the case that the finals were a
four game match but not this time and I
actually quite like that choice I think
uh the players are are obviously
exhausted by now a four game match that
might be a little bit of Overkill so
format is going to be exactly the same
as for all of the other matches two
games and then uh August 6 will be a
tiebreaker as we take one quick look of
course at our bracket we have karyapan
uh against
Carlson for
the third place match
um well before we jump into these
delightful matchups of course we're
going to take a very quick first break
and uh we're gonna let uh Yvonne we're
gonna let the players settle down but
this is going to be this is going to be
epic there's just that feeling in the
air
and we are going to take a quick break
when we come back the first moves of the
final of the fide World Cup 2021 will be
played don't go anywhere the games are
about to begin
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
okay and as we see the players recording
the information and the handshakes and
the games have begun at the final World
Cup 2021 buckle your seat belts
if on this promises to be epic uh Duda
has been playing completely out of his
mind and honestly that's been the story
of the tournament
how do you think he's gonna fare against
Sergey today
uh well but we saw that today dude that
wait uh he's having black misses okay
yeah I mean it's definitely going to be
very very the I mean exciting and
decisive but to be honest I I don't know
do that very well I mean about his
chance of course he's super strong and
he doesn't lose a single game yet in the
world cup and we'll see whether he will
keep his record until the final uh but
for somehow it's hard for me really to
expect what dude that will perform and
how he gonna take it but in general I
thought his his already showed an
amazing performance and he's going to
play the candidate I'm not sure if he
already anticipated that before he came
to the World Cup that's a definitely a
great achievement for him and if if he
want to work out that we you have
meaning more
yeah I mean I hope that uh he has no
siblings that will have weddings or you
know everything will have to be canceled
because John should stop me and the
candidate so we're just gonna have to
move some stuff around
um all the bachelor parties that have to
get moved and it is something that you
know 2700 plus players they've got to be
they've got to know that they have a
chance but I mean so many people you
could make a case for so many players
winning and when Magnus is playing
I mean nobody's coming to the World Cup
other than Magnuson saying I'm
definitely going to make the candidates
uh but of course uh as we saw in the
case of kayakan svidler it's it's one
thing to make the candidates that's
great but losing in the final is is
incredibly painful in its own right and
it's not necessarily because of the
money it's also because you've made it
this far and uh you know and and you've
lost just at the last moment now
something very interesting and fun they
are repeating the Vienna Gambit or not
the Vienna Gambit but this is also
called the Vienna by the way when people
think of the Vienna Gambit they think E4
E5 Knight C3 and F4
this happened in Buddhist game
against
two against man this was Carlson Carlson
Duda from game one
yeah
and the dude that repeated the same
variation Knight F6 seems like he has
full confidence when we see here Sergey
updated the move he played the same time
Queen A4 check
[Music]
grenade for check
yeah maybe he'll go some noisy 695
plastic classic idea across many
different lines I mean you're trying to
take on C6 Bishop D7 is generally
where Bishop takes C3 I guess are the
antidotes to that
Judah has to know what to do here this
is this seems to be something you would
prepare for
now it's interesting that it repeats the
line you find that's a against karyakkin
you know it's a repeat but also Sergey
is not a D4 player
uh yeah it's not he said you for a
player but recent years Simpson is also
about Universal but I don't think it
applies a theme for very often sometimes
it might play like C4 Knight F3 this
kind of things
yeah players around their level I guess
could handle everything ah drug B8 oh
that's a cool move and it creates
contact between the rook and the bishop
that will
open up in the events of Knight takes C6
you're gonna I assume take with the pawn
and then the Rook is going to be
defending that Bishop this idea also
exists
uh in some other lines
and
I'm trying to understand
why Sergey is off
oh he sat back down I guess that is his
move uh
jacket maybe it seems like he started
thinking I'm not sure if he's happy or
he suddenly felt like he didn't check
in-depth as oxygen drug ba it's probably
this is not something he paid most of
his attention
yeah and I like how I'm speculating on
you know is is it still his preparation
he's just taking his jacket off like
he's just hot it's just hot on the
playing Hall and I can imagine after the
tournament so Sergey tell us about the
taking off of the jacket what did that
mean about
you know about whether it was
preparation uh it was just hot in the
playing Hall
all right so let's let's explore some of
White's options here the most obvious is
to take on C6
I would imagine yeah black takes of
course forced
but now which point to take
yeah so if you take this one
yeah
that's not terribly impressed I mean
queen F3
maybe just Castle
yeah let's say something like Bishop G5
for instance
um Bishop E7
yep the structure okay one got this
isolated pump but I also have a c and a
pawn but seems like
this could be equalized
it should be three and
oh you won the gold B3
yeah B3 is probably better just uh yeah
not sure if white could get some
initiatives
yeah I think White's flying for a small
edge here
yeah even one day you push D5 and they
probably just Supply position knowledge
with the two isolated points on the
queen side for black
right CNA yeah I mean if dude I analyze
this to death I mean maybe he knows how
to equalize here that's one option
um and perhaps black has more accurate
ways of developing here that yeah maybe
questions we are not forced to play
Bishop D7
there any other options maybe like Queen
D7
oh so maybe the bishop can come to B7
yeah and keep their uh kpi for this D4
Pawn as well maybe this is a better one
windy seven is is really interesting
yeah as far as I thought Bishop Nissan
okay very natural but this is like kind
of force move
right because if white takes them the
end game is completely innocuous but
clearly fine for black
and if white drops the queen of F3 Queen
takes D4 is not out of the question
but uh maybe it's dangerous because of
Bishop B5 check but you don't need you
don't need that I think you can probably
Castle
um
G3 yeah I was worried a little bit about
Queen G3 and then so I'm sure this is
fine for black two castles Bishop H6
and then if black plays this correctly
but maybe even Queen D4 now who knows
um
yeah this is not worth it I guess for
for black
um but but I like I like the idea of
going
castles straight away or or finding
something after Bishop B7 in G3 so but
but in any case I think Queen D7 is is
in fact the likeliest move if crayakan
takes twice he's taken on C6 by the way
so
yeah and there's also taking on A7 of
course which we haven't looked at
rookie one plant
what is his idea if short Castle
do you want to snag that pawn on A7 and
then come back
but he can do directly with other fd1
right exactly the question is why would
he do this if you wanted to take that
pawn
so let's say I mean I assume level
Castle
yeah
maybe he wants to keep the possibilities
and develop the C1 Bishop first but it's
hard because if you go Bishop F4 you
always face Knight D5
right
or and if you go Mr G5 then there's
Bishop E7
which which
yeah I guess uh it's the current Eagle
moment for circa to decide which poem to
take and I still didn't get out get get
the point of this stroke D1 maybe just
wants to avoid any Queen D4 forcing
variations and keep game going on
yeah but not taking any of these funds I
mean that's like you're offered free
sandwiches
um you know roast beef or BLT you got to
take one of them
uh you can't just not take either Pawn
right I mean they don't just fly by the
side of the road I mean you got to take
one the queen takes a seven makes sense
because this creates an outside passer
and in any end game
that pawn could be pretty dangerous
but I guess well I can play this move
which looks bad Bishop B7 I was thinking
but maybe eventually try to get C5 in
I mean clearly that's not good but the
move like Bishop A6
trying to force the exchange
right yeah no that's interesting that's
interesting but it worse case the black
can play Bishop a a oh wait about them
Bishop
Bishop F4 Bishop D6 yeah I mean worst
case
right
yeah Bishop drops back or maybe bishop
A5 threatening Bishop B6
uh yeah so then we have to go back
Bishop
Bishop C Bishop C8 maybe oh my goodness
that's a that's an amazing move Bishop
C8 because now The Rook is hanging so
if black drops back the bishop oh my God
look at this look at the sequence Auto
but then the bishop on eight is saying I
was thinking something even crazier I
thought that for just a second I thought
but but if there's also Bishop C7 but
Bishop on A8 is also hanging so this is
very tricky we do not surround command
the most of the players to you know self
trouble on the corner like this not in
the final of the World Cup yeah
absolutely
oh it's this this position is insane
Rigby too
um the likelihood that this happens I
mean it's not zero because if karyakan
takes them
you know Bishop B7 is one of the top
candidate moves for her
for Duda Rook B6 is also possible maybe
Rook B7 Rook B7 seems a little bit
awkward that Rook is neither here nor
there after Queen A4
um
so who knows who knows who knows what
what dude is going to do here he's
probably still in his preparation after
Queen A7
like if you knew how to react to Queen
A7 here
and probably he's going to do the same
thing after Rook D1 castles okay so hey
how are you gonna react to from Queen A7
without Rook D1
yeah well I mean I'm not sure but he's
gonna react the same way after Rook D1
this before but yeah I think I think
Bishop B7 here is still possible
yeah but maybe he's gonna do something
like rugby seven then Queen takes D4
oh see what you're saying is maybe there
was a difference
uh well unlikely I really don't like
this idea of Queen takes D4 but who
knows that seems really dangerous Queen
takes c66 Rook B6
also should be taken very seriously I
guess
or maybe there's some crazy move we're
not factoring in
um Bishop D7 also exists oh so has been
played after Rook D1 oh so here's the
thing
after Queen takes a seven there's a
there's a draw
uh Rook a eight Queen B7 Rook B8
and the queen cannot Escape
the Wrath Of The Rook
wow this commentary might last four
seconds
well we might be watching for the save
Carlson
we're not going to do to our school
following Carlson and Duda it's out of
steel 2019.
wow I had no idea
yeah me too that changes a lot that
changes a lot then then they must be
both aware of this
yeah so I wonder what Magnus played here
um and we think our incredibly
hard-working producers Vic always
supplying really cool information that
helps us a lot
[Music]
um
and Rook D1 is the new move
broken one is the new move
you thought I'm going to say something
mean
um I'm not terribly impressed with Rook
D1 as a novelty
I'm sorry I'm sorry but I I don't find
Rook D1 to be like oh wow well you're
brave to express it here you know during
the broadcast I believe you are not the
only one but not many probably would say
in this way this is a highly
controversial statement but I was just
thinking you know uh because Sergey was
thinking before he went now he's
thinking again I'm not sure it might be
his strategy to go for some equal
oppositions and letting the match go to
the tie break with the full confidence
which is black business or maybe he has
something in mind because now we
understood he's not thinking uh for the
moves he probably you know try to recall
something so I'm just wondering what he
will react in the next few moves
I think there's a there's an off chance
that he just wants to develop his pieces
and say forget about the pawns I'm going
to go Bishop G5 Rook C1
and I'm gonna play against blacks week
pawn structure
the reason I feel like this doesn't
promise that much is you know black has
the D5 score for the night
and I don't know
um again when you're analyzing with
computers everything comes down to
concrete details
and it's very easy to look at a position
and say oh this is not impressive but uh
karyakan might have analyzed something
20 moves deep where he might understand
the ideas on a deeper level
and and it's very important to
understand that so he's thinking after
Bishop B7 we will revisit this position
and see whether he takes on Ace if he
takes on A7 then the game is going to
end in a very quick draw
yeah maybe some three five exchanges a
night and then 94 95 Queen C two to play
something possessionally and remind me
of the ideas
something like this and then this I mean
Maybe not immediately but at some point
yeah that's interesting
okay
the other game will have them talk about
Samsung Magna start to start a long
think after moves right
uh let's say issues but now I realize
he's really thinking
yeah he's thinking after and H4
has has been uh very popular lately but
asev has played this move against me
online probably a hundred times
so I'm not I'm not surprised to see it
played
uh in this game against Carlson it's
acquired a lot of legitimacy
and a lot of players who haven't or a
lot of people who haven't seen this move
before will be thinking that how to save
his trolling or that this is again this
is a transmission error of a different
kind
but in fact
um and and we discussed this I think in
a previous broadcast H4 early age four
in many different openings has become
pretty mainstream
[Music]
maybe show us some other
some other kind of opening
company that's a great I mean of course
there's there's the old example of the
trumpowski bishop G5 94 H4 but this is
H4 for a different reason
but uh in in an old in a blitz
tournament I think two years ago
Kasparov started playing H4 in a nimso
Indian
um in this line c-46 Knight C3 Bishop B4
I don't remember exactly which uh which
position okay but you know this line
with with um what is it A3 Bishop C3
Queen C3 castles
in Bishop G5 here here B6 and one of
these positions required started playing
H4 and I think that's kind of what
started it
um this this got a lot of attention and
then people started playing H4 in
various positions
yeah you're reminded me also I I
remember I applied with black uh I
played Black uh with us named Indian and
also I faced the yh4 back to the year of
2010 also in the world championship this
knockout system and also in the line
Queen C2
and I remember there was some cd5 that
h24 okay
so like D5 cd5
yeah some Bishop G okay I don't remember
exactly
but it was something
H4 that was uh I'm not sure it's exactly
the novelty but uh until it's not the
mainstream
and turned out to be also very tough
yeah it's hard to refute these moves now
like it's a little hard to explain what
the idea of H4 is here because it's not
that white wants to play H5 now
uh this is way too premature uh you
don't want to um
so let's play Bishop G7 I think the idea
is to play
C3 uh wait until D5 cd9 E5 and then go
for H5 uh but I guess the question here
is whether Mac let's play G6 for
Greenfield or he plays three six for
Kings India yeah I mean I selfishly hope
it's for Kings Indian also maybe maybe
he played it for grunfeld but now seeing
H4
he might transition to the king's Indian
with D6
um and we've already seen H4 before in
the World Cup Shanklin beats Fiddler
with 3h4 in round five
so um
preparation and so they'll play some bad
Queen moves and just lose immediately is
that one right it is that one and I
don't know what svidler played there um
Fiddler of course is a grunfell player
but as you Illustrated Define here you
can't really be stubborn and
forcibly under the groomfield because
you might meet you might allow H5
so you have to be flexible and that
means one of a couple of things you can
play it in a benoni way I've seen a lot
of people
go C5
and basically claim well it's a good
benoni with this Pawn on H4 well Magnus
is finally making moves he fought for
for 17 18 minutes that's that's a long
time he's gone Bishop G7
Knight C3 and D6
yes he's gonna play Kings Indian
I'm happy
this is going to be juicy but
I'm just wondering because you mentioned
the feathers have played let's say uh
would you like a lot but let's get into
his H football whether he played some
let's say serious chess or classical one
so it's H4 all very rare I don't think
so uh but I mean I wouldn't rule it out
if I had to save loves these kinds of
lines as we all already know
and he's got an E4 so we have a Mainline
King's Indian with essentially this
could have Arisen via King's Indian
move order
and imagine again imagine capablanca or
you know some uh early world champion
looking at this position already the
king's Indian would be a surprise then
they would see H4 like what does chess
come to
um
yeah exactly this would have gotten you
banned from a tournament for trolling
all right so again black has a choice
now normally in the king is Indian in
the main line black castles at this
point
but this pawn and H4 is going to make
you think twice about castling I don't
know whether white is supposed to play
H5 and Sack an exchange on H5
or if white plays something more
measured like Bishop E2 to prepare H5
yeah this either move looks unpleasant
so maybe black should delayed the short
castle and trying to create some counter
play in the center
starting from the move
well it's hard because E5 D5 and the C5
may be
maybe dc5 oh dc5
dc5 and then generally you play Queen A5
in these in these spaces
and I think I just say D5 because I
think that's what for to say I've played
online and many times I remember trying
a Banco Gambit type idea B5
wow and
cba6 this is actually pretty common
uh but I was I always failed to equalize
like I I never was able to to get a
viable position
and this constant threat of H5
coupled with the fact that it's just
there's just not enough compensation in
these positions so
but it's something Magnus must be
considering
yeah or maybe he'll start some might be
these seven first
but white can just develop like Bishop
E2 and already throughout the H5 and
it's always a problem for black whether
to push H5 or not
right and I mean black can play it
standard King's Indian fashion with E5
D5 Knight C5
and I wonder how how FedEx is going to
go about defending this Pawn now F3
would not go very well with H4 if you
play F3 here it weakens the G3 Square
black and go Knight H5 I don't like that
at all yeah maybe probably Queen Bishop
F3 actually is a nice move or queen C2
yeah crazy two probably even stronger
but Bishop F3 now we have two
things are the same B4 and H5
right and H5 is particularly on black
would probably have to go H5 yeah
this is simply bad for black
agreed
yeah Quincy was much stronger you even
have C5 that's probably coming very soon
yeah once the Knight has to drop back
for it this is always a bad sign when
the king is Indian
man
the move A5 trying to
trying to cut into this Pawn into the
spawn fillings is an important resource
but white can prepare for it by playing
for instance A3 or Rook B1 I mean
an ic6 okay yeah preparing E5
yeah that's
that's interesting Knight T6 first
and just to show if you've got any five
straight away then you run into D takes
C5 because black is uncastled
uh you're gonna have to move your king
out and This is highly undesirable it's
not the end of the world for black but
you you don't want this to happen and
you know in the first because black has
no winning chances there
yeah
also sometimes after after you play E5
wire has a line of feedback TD5 and now
you've got your king moving around
losing the chances of castles just seems
like not
until it's in favor of black
right
okay so finally Vladimir well not
finally it's only move six but he's
thinking for the first time in this
tournament
and there's a couple of things to
consider for right I mean first of all
white always has to consider D5 here
but E5 yeah that's generally the idea
now we've got this three four square
since the Palm already on H4 so after F4
the ninth will happily jump to G4
yeah this is a great Square so that's
yeah I thought maybe you start with
Bishop B2
um
H5 here
yeah
and then you know this is not
particularly
you know
crazy Knight F3 I'm just playing trying
to play for a small advantage
making it harder for black to push Bonds
in the center but I think black is fine
here you could even take and go Knight
G4
and this is a classic King's Indian
position you know C6 Queen B6
I think black's totally fine here
yeah
that you know that appetizing
yeah because the structure is kind of
fixed and it's hard to tell what white
is a whole game for if you push D5 so I
guess probably why shouldn't be hurry to
push the pawn
and try to maybe now he should try some
like F3 Bishop e390 to idea because in
that case H4 is actually a meaningful
move
yeah right so you're saying F3
immediately
well it's a bit weird though on the
other on the other case well look how
look
H4 you might as well take some risks
yeah so I guess E5
yeah Knight D4
and in the generally in the same
Michigan too
yeah then you got C5
right and you get this
you get this potential Pawn sacrifice on
poisson and then black
you know there's a very important detail
here that some people Overlook which is
that if black tries to take on E2 first
here there might be even CB B7 yeah yeah
oftentimes there's C7 giving away The
pontic Preserve the bad Pawn structure
for black not allow the b-pawn to move
to C6
uh but here that's a moot point because
CB exists as well
uh but black will sack on on D4 I mean
the king's Indian you don't you know you
don't worry about Pawn sacks
and you get a position also short yeah
this is a variable for black
right
due to this uh totally exposure of the
can the white now if you're worried
about you know when he could Castle
yeah and where to Castle because the
opponent H2 still can play like special
B2 short Castle but here
no this is this is I mean there's also
an x-ray going against the queen
now you're regretting the pawn on H4
because then H5 is coming
all right so this is this is not not the
recipe for success
um but
white doesn't have to of course take the
take the pawn on C6 might can simply
leave this Knight on D4 I've seen this
played like this and I was always
surprised
uh but white can make a move such as
Knight G3
wow
and somehow
um even though you have this incredible
looking knight after something like H5
Bishop G5
why does a plan of going Bishop D3
and then castling and eventually
preparing F4
and it's not as easy to deal with it as
one may think uh so that's that's a
modern chess for you just leaving a
night on D4 like this
that is remarkable because most of the
players might think okay it's a standard
night because in this type of structure
normally Black's not supposed to be
somewhere on E7 or maybe D7 but now he's
on D4 same size black will be happy for
that but so we'll just leave the start
doing nothing in the middle and trying
to create some side attacks so that
reminds me some similar structure in
Social incorporation of Sicilian there's
one now I like Bishop J5 Bishop F6
Bishop F6 C4
and the one day black might also brings
the 9 to D4 and the white simply leave
is not here and the place are more like
Knight cities or some similar ideas but
of course not exactly the same because
that position is more open and here is
really closed but that's a good company
I know what you mean Black Knight on D4
you're just gonna leave it there uh just
because the pieces on an outpost I guess
what it illustrates it doesn't mean that
you know that you can't do anything
um and and I quite like this approach I
think F3 is a good move it's it's risky
but
uh but but I think it flies
it flies so it's it's it's not unlikely
that fed a safe place but what you
probably don't want to do
and you could go Knight F3
I assume that maybe this this isn't
great because of Bishop G4
yeah
before but you know you could go but
should be two here and it's and it's
honestly not that bad
um normally in the king's Indian first
black doesn't go Bishop too far that is
a line of the king's Indian but
it's not necessarily and you might get a
similar situation E5 D5 Bishop F3 and
the knight's gonna plan itself on D4
again
and again maybe black white is happy to
see this
but now is the one uh let's say with
some exchange I guess that will be in
favor of black
yeah
something like maybe G3 Bishop G2 short
castle and trying to develop the king
side
right G3 Bishop G2 that is similar to
the station of C4 session
a sort of kind of situation you get with
the bishop there
yeah
um several options on on the cards here
for for Vladimir and as he thinks about
how to handle Knight C6 let's check back
into our game
between kariak and Duda
or Sergey has gone Bishop G5 after a
really long think
he has oh no no he hasn't he hasn't he
has my apologies where has he
no no no he has played Bishop Q5
he has played Bishop G5 but this just
happened so
I took a moment to update
and we were talking about Bishop B7 here
being
a pretty likely
you know pretty likely option from Duda
on pinning himself and opening up The
Rook I'm sure it's not forced
if there's other ways to handle this
position
yeah unless you play C5 I mean that's
crazy not a good option
yeah C5 would be premature
even Queen takes A7 is probably possible
now
and okay
we have three yeah
yeah right this used to be a draw
but now the queen drops back to F3
so so C5 is out of the question
Bishop B7 is one candidate move I guess
you could play H6 and force the bishop
to decide
for them Bishop F6 Queen A7
right and then I guess castles
I'm blundering C7 yeah
Queen by 58 yeah
yeah
and you get a structure like this
I guess White's playing for a tiny
Advantage here but
I'm still not like
I I don't see Duda getting in big
trouble here I feel like he's quite
comfortable in these positions
so we'll see what decision he makes
After Bishop G5 but we are going to go
on
our first well first break of the day
after the games have begun you've got
some we've got two very interesting
positions uh we're closely following the
final of the theater Worlds Cup and of
course we're looking at the third place
match carefully as well because it
involves the world champion got some
interesting developments there don't go
anywhere we'll be back in a few minutes
with more World Cup action
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Championship is coming your way in
November it'll be held in Dubai between
two relatively unknown players and
Bobby and uh not Fabiana Magnus Carlson
but uh Fabiana karawana he's the 2018
Challenger and we are delighted to
announce that uh chats.com welcomes Fabi
to the world championship commentary
team with with Robert Tess it's going to
be absolutely lit
um you will not want to miss the
broadcast particularly because josh.com
has the exclusive uh video feeds of the
World Championship on Twitch so this is
your One-Stop place for Fabi for the
video feeds for Magnus uh make sure
uh you take an extended vacation in
November to watch the World Chess
Championship well we hope you're taking
an extended vacation right now because
we got the finals of the World Cup going
on
we're watching kariakin play Duda in the
finals and Magnus play feta Sam in the
third place match
and right now The Duda game uh you found
Bishop E7
has been played
and kuryakyn's currently contemplating
his Expo
but I'm just a bit surprised to see that
serious spend a lot of time here
according to our production team's
information that uh the queen for 95 do
that as a game right so this is not
something new and I guess Rook D1 is his
preparation but he spent a lot of time
not I guess not recording his
preparation this must be some new
position not like exactly new he might
have some similar ideas but just to say
this concrete position he thinking by
himself well that's a bit weird to be
honest we all know his master in Palm
preparation that he showed in the tiger
versus some Jacqueline
yeah we do and I think we were talking
about Queen C2
and it is basically abandoning the pawns
and saying I'm not going to take them
and you know
after counseling why doesn't why doesn't
compelled to take immediately but but
the bottom line idea here might be to
take and if you notice the C5 Square the
night swings around you know it's a
little bit of a clamp a little bit of
clamp
the first time I blacked up upon two
Bishops I don't you like black as any
issues here
yeah
I'm skeptical just to play something
simple like Queen E7 or EA to bring the
rock targeting the D4 poll and the one
day you retrieve the bishop to E8 you
know just stays here even double the
road
would be hard but we'll see what white
can do
right maybe maybe you should double the
Rooks on the D file and swing one of the
Rooks over to G3
I stopped
you're saying okay
yeah yeah okay whatever wait isn't that
a draw
yeah wait a second wait a second are we
about to see the game end
where am I am I dumb
Queen someone's reply
that's a draw for
my am I am I hallucinating it's okay
it's okay a repetition
by the way I was thinking you can play
Bishop F6 0.7 no but that rock takes B2
because in that case you're okay well
face Queen C5 oh so you wanted to open
up a square for the queen
I don't rookie it's a drop
we are watching the Magnus game today
and kariakin in 10 moves he just decided
that he's not creating any difficulties
I agree with this decision given the
position I think if he retreated his
Queen
Duda has no problems there and a draw
for
uh essentially a dropper when droppers
are not allowed is to offer a three-time
repetition
and the first game of the finals
relatively anti-climactic as it ends in
a quick draw
the petition is claimed
and confirmed by the Arbiter
Jan Kristoff yifon has to be happy he
holds a quick draw with the black pieces
he's gonna have white tomorrow
yeah yakin has been insane with white
this tournament
yeah maybe he just wants to get through
the tie breaks with the full of
confidence
right but what worries me is that dude
is going to have what dude is going to
play Full Tilt tomorrow
yeah but which is a solid opening with
Sergey well definitely helping some
pressure
right he'll try but yeah I agree Sergey
is so solid with black
and uh sergey's only lost well yeah he
lost to Sam that was the only match he
really struggled in I feel like
wow but he did lose a lot of games with
black to Sam
um and he's gonna have to make some
changes he's going to have to build and
learn from that
and wow 43 minute game that might be the
shortest shortest game we've seen in a
while
now it has to be I I have to always say
in these in these moments it is
disappointing for fans who were hoping
for
you know let's say something more higher
energy
but I have to say that these players
they they have their own considerations
and you know how the expression goes
before judging someone walk a mile in
their shoes you know maybe kriyakins
woke up exhausted today you never know
and if you're in his shoes it may make
perfect sense to make a draw here so I'm
completely on that train I wish this
game was really entertaining but I also
understand that there are realities on
the ground these players are facing
which can be hard to wrap your head
around for just sort of I didn't put
anything for the win
yeah so at the end of the day trust you
know trust is still a competition right
so in the competition you have the
skills but you also have the strategy so
it depends on which perspective you're
looking if you are looking from the
trust funds of followers it definitely
hope something let's say a real fight
because you don't care so much wait of
course you might have someone you
support but as a player themselves they
have to consider more they will think
about it in what what type of situation
they will have the most chances to win
the title I guess that's their priority
they don't care the process that much
right which and and I think you make a
great point and I think it should be
their priority I think that what gives
chess is high level chest its beauty is
the objectivity with which the players
approach uh the art of trying to win
these tournaments
and uh if yeah sorry go ahead
yeah yeah that was always going to say
just that uh you know this is what lens
chess it's it's scientific aspect these
players are searching for the best
strategy for the truth and the position
uh whatever that may mean
mm-hmm
uh what were you gonna say
and there I I just wanted to say that uh
following your comments like they are
able to make the most rational decisions
that's also important because they know
and what at what point they do what as
you say it's a property so you can just
wake up and thought today it's not his
day so he just suddenly changed his mind
that's also possible so we never know
because we're not the one who's there
playing the finals
yeah but sometimes when you come to the
board and that doesn't necessarily mean
you're out partying you know the night
before you just might wake up and feel
you know
kind of crappy it's it just happens and
Sergey is he's human everybody can
relate to that and you need your brain
firing and all firing on all cylinders
when
when you're playing a file like this but
dude has got to be even more exhausted
he had a tie break against some dude
named Magnus yesterday
pretty easy stuff right I mean beating
Magnus in the cybreak come on anybody
could do it
yeah therefore I thought that today to
have a let's say a quick day to have
some rest so it would be very welcome
before do that list especially he got
black pieces
yeah maybe Judas going back to us Army's
just gonna pass out after yesterday's
matches like I'm taking the extra sleep
although I guess it's afternoon and
Sochi
all right so uh well we've got basically
one game and that's Magnus against
Vladimir
and Magnus did decide uh on on the Move
D5 here very principled id5 and Bishop
E2 which we talked about H5
and now Bishop F4 just developing his
bishop and Yvonne you mentioned an
important point this would be bad
because the Knight entrenches itself on
G4 this is a huge Outpost you do not
want to yield this Outpost for free
Bishop F4
and
um black to play I guess
this is a very interesting move because
the black needs to decide whether you
will allow Bishop E5 or you do not want
to allow that I guess that's a serious
question
look at that camera work
oh
never want to see the color of the same
time
the first time that oh we're following
this camera where can I saw that there's
the focus on the own persons let's say
this part of the face
right that's some serious Zoom right
there
and um
that can only be
um
like you know those can only be the eyes
of Vladimir fedesv
and um
yeah
wow that's cool that was cool okay and
we just got to realize like I remember
you know when I was following uh live
tournaments
2010 or so uh when the camera feeds
first began to be a thing there was a
time when you know perhaps some of the
younger uh members of of the chat in the
audience might this might be
mind-boggling like you used to just look
at the board like you were like in the
cameras just looking at the board or No
cameras of the tournament then the
cameras appeared and it was just one
View
and the cameras down a lot of the time
now we got try to save his eyes and
magnus's face and his hair and and we
got the playing Hall and uh it's it's
it's great to watch tournaments now it's
really it adds such an element of
intrigue but yeah there used to be a
time when
uh none of this existed so
I guess it's cool I guess it's uh I'm
I'm really happy that that we're able to
enjoy this in this way
definitely because uh thanks to our
let's say camera work I realized they
too are having the different style I
mean talking about the appearance
of this kind of things before right
right exactly but now yeah now you have
no choice but to pay attention to that
um and it is disconcerting I you know
the first the only tournament I've
played in with this kind of level of
camera work was is the US Championship
because every board has a webcam
directly trained on your face
and that really uh what what that does
is it raises your level of Consciousness
in the sense like if you blundered uh
normally you know you you can show some
emotion but here it's like I I remember
just being completely emotionless the
whole game I mean I'm normally pretty
unemotional at the board but I was
especially just like everybody might be
watching my game right now I'm not I'm
not gonna go crazy
okay so you even pay attention to that
because for me I was like okay with
camera without camera it's basically the
same thing and yeah yeah never checked
let's say trying to check the video of
my camera although I did it with uh to
to follow others but I never tried to
follow myself so I don't know how I
might be look like through the camera
there but I wouldn't think okay how
should I behave the next time right well
that's the right approach
um but the first I I this is more so the
very first time I played in 2011. once
once I got into the groove it it became
second nature but
um I remember the first time it being
pretty
pretty interesting experience but these
players are totally used to the
spotlight it's what makes them nervous
if they are nervous isn't it isn't the
fact that there are cameras and 20 000
people watching it that you know
tournaments on the line
and
um
well like Nino continuing to think he's
below an hour
yeah as we said before before this
camera discussions after Bishop F4 black
needs to decide whether to avoid Bishop
E5 D E5 or not but if you wanted to
avoid there are not so many options
because you cannot jump to gu4 you do
not want to retreat to D7 because if you
go 197 white may just try some move like
Bishop tree sorry the F4 will become a
strat at some moments
right yeah for F4 always needs to be
reckoned with whenever you have a knight
on E5 like that
and I guess in response to a move like
C6 C6 it feels to me because it creates
immediate you know immediate pressure on
White Center I think if white if black
plays too cooperatively White's going to
bring out all his pieces and be better
although maybe black can just Castle it
there's nothing wrong with just castling
here
I think right
and I wonder what Vladimir is going to
do here's a queen D2 is it Knight F3 how
is he going to
deal with this position
because Knight F3 I don't know I mean
takes takes and we talked about
something similar to 94. yeah or Knight
C7 back to you the other night comes to
E5 and then eventually you want to play
C6 and queen B6 and all that jazz
all right
let's see what Magnus says I feel like
he's about to make a move he just has
that
yeah I can turn his head back
he just has that look eight moves in but
he's not got a lot of time
but it says took a while on Bishop F4
though
yeah maybe he wants to you know wait to
see the black's Direction
he wants to delay this noise of three
right I know after short Castle how
about F3
and it's very weird here
no I mean it makes sense you wanna first
of all you want to solidify your Center
and G4 at some point is not out of the
question but I played C6 here Knight H3
Queen B6
Queen D2
yeah
and I guess probably I'll play uh maybe
there's some Bishop H3 Queen G1
is there Bishop H3 Queen G1
uh uh yeah I'm clearly I missed it
okay he's made a move
is it D6
well Bishop H3 I have Bishop E3
then Queen okay oh you have an
instrument so he's played a move I can't
make it out Shores Castle hit play oh he
castle Yeah Okay so
wow it's our camera work is even more
artistic It's So Meta like we're seeing
the camera do the camera the camera
capturing the camera
and also you see the the artistic
flowers and the pieces in front
yeah that's
it's honestly a lovely part of watching
tournaments it's just uh
you know you don't have to be a a
experienced wrestlers or appreciate the
competitive quality of it and the fact
that you can see all the players and all
the emotions on their face
it just adds to the to the level of
intrigue
Okay so
yeah so Magnus has castles
and Vladimir is thinking about how to
position his pieces so what are the
Canada moves you suggested F3 if on
there's Knight F3 there's Queen D2 or C2
I don't know yeah two and Bishop H6
would be
or even Knight H3 immediately because F3
is actually all necessary
so you go Knight G5 then shortcut so
maybe that's one of the ways
yeah
white could end up being slightly better
here you know because
cdcd
I've I've had a ton of these positions
with black and
this spot on D5 is annoying it stops you
from from ever really going E6
and white is a simple plan you know
short castles Queen D2 Rook C1 oh arrow
drawing has been even below below my
usual Shady standards
but um yeah I I quite like uh feather
save's opening choice this H4 against
Magnus it takes some
you know take some take some guts to do
that and uh he
he he didn't hesitate I'm if I didn't
save his life that he doesn't care who
he's playing he plays this he plays the
same thing against against anybody
doesn't care if it's Magnus or schmagnus
yeah that that's actually a very uh
unusual and I guess precious uh let's
say ability because most of the players
might just suffering to where you play
let's say 2008 or 2004 right it could be
completely different
right
and
okay so let's talk about some weird
ideas like developing the king-sider
pieces and we'll talk about Queen D2
well I don't see many other options to
be honest
yeah
it's definitely we need to it's going to
be one of those moves
and uh yeah but the question is how
likely you're going to play Bishop H6 so
we do not need this move at this
earliest stage I guess I agree
and I mean the reason for example after
C6 Bishop H6 is just not uh that looks
very bad take stakes in Queen B6
you know just all these threats
it's not like it's made yeah
wait maybe black is something even
stronger here I'm not ruling that out
and always you know in these positions
you have to watch for
you know this queen F2 check idea
yeah
I think you have two knights before so
this always exists when White Queen is
on H6 and the king is on castled
um
all right so Mr fedo save is
contemplating his next move
the camera it feels like Carlson today
is nothing a very
spirits to play this came by the law I
mean his body language just shows
something like that yeah why could that
be
match yeah I was talking on my stream uh
yesterday uh Magnus tweeted a very
gracious and I have to say Magnus is
always very very gracious in defeat uh
so what I'm about to say is entirely
humorous I I'm in no way
uh trying to disparage uh magnus's very
professional always graceful Behavior
uh but uh you know there was a tweet
issued shortly after his loss to Duda
you know congratulations
kind of stuff played a main thing and I
could just I could just Envision you
know magnus's manager typing up the
tweet and Magnus is sitting in his house
it's going crazy uh so he definitely is
not in a good mood and uh I think
somebody and perhaps we could confirm
this I wonder how many times the top
seed has won the World Cup I would
imagine that it's not a lot
these tournaments are rarely won by by
the top seat
yeah that's a good question
okay so we can recall so uh last last
time there was
um
who's the last time oh I drive off
who was definitely not the top seed
oh because he defeated ding lyron in the
final or who was it uh
last time yep
who was definitely high rated than him
and then kamsky who won it in 2000
him probably is one of the top six
maybe not right might have been the top
seed
well I remember yeah he's not exactly
the top but I guess maybe top five or
six because in the year he while I
played him in the second round so I
remember I was somewhere in the middle
so what if I seen the second round I
guess probably he's one of the top
states
right
yeah that'll be an interesting thing to
look up and I started watching the World
Cup that your Mac of the year kimski one
I think and kamski did knock Magnus out
that was a long time ago uh girlfriends
come in 2009. amazing statistic
statistical research wow
fun in 2009 the only time so the odds
were stacked against Magnus this
tournament
it's hard the pressures on you as the
top seed and and you got to beat a
gazillion bloodthirsty GMS
they need to even if you're Magnus
yeah gelf funds
wow that was already 12 years ago
yeah it's weird when you think about
that 2009
seems like a different I mean it's 2019
seems like a different name
it was nine well because all of that
actually was also my first World Cup
who did you play in the first round but
um
not to put you on the side I didn't mean
that in a quit in a pop quiz kind of way
and the ones I played with more
Obsession and the other time played with
knowledge so I cannot remember exactly
who my planning which year
how dare you I'm unacceptable you can't
remember who you played in 2009 uh
poor memory but what is it do you feel
like uh World Cup is significantly like
do you treat it differently than other
tournaments you
you know it's weird for me I've never
played a knockout chess tournament
before as weird as that sounds I've
never played in a knockout tournament
oh really yeah it's it's got to be this
weird Sensation that like the pressure
is immense even in the first round like
you gotta book your ticket home
if you lose
uh yeah
so uh well uh I mean for World Cup I
just trying to think about okay so which
one I probably most likely to getting
and get out so I just have this
estimation right but for woman's I I
wasn't in charge of that time I mean I
think the team was taking care of those
kind of things but of course for women's
I guess so
well I have the tickets for the last
round yeah so
I think it's different because for
example in women's section I I know that
mostly like that will have a good
resource unless those one year in 2012 I
lost in the second round all the other
experiences were kind of fine I mean I
think my first time but in the open
sector it's really hard to expect to be
honest every time I have the mindset
that I might be back very soon or a bit
later that's it that's how I say to my
friends and to my school
right right just just a little bit okay
so magnets still kind of have three
it makes a lot of sense
um I like that move
yeah uh because it it strengthens White
Center you'll see this pretty often in
these positions why trying to exploit
the fact that he hasn't castles yet
and you know Queen D2 Bishop H6 Rook G1
don't rule out a king side attack
um That's a classic kind of savory
capture and C6 by Magnus so Magnus
trying to preemptively open you know
we've already talked about C6 creating
some pressure in the center opening up
an Avenue for the queen to come to B6 or
A5 and you know potential B5 ideas as
well
without wasting any time for the safe
windy too
yeah g hex F3 we ignore that this is
clearly a good move
yeah and
Vladimir might keep his King in the
center or he might Castle Queen inside
I like this position here yeah maybe
just Castle can be one or three one
Bishop H6
because the question is black is very
hard to create an encounter ply it's a
queen side development is very slow and
New York coin well maybe you can go
Queen A5 at some moments and try to play
57 CD Queen A5 World Cup C8 maybe this
one right some something like this
another thing you could try to do to buy
yourself some time is King H7 uh to try
that's a I feel like that's what Magnus
might do that's a Magnus move to stop
Bishop H6 now King might get misplaced
later on you know if the bishop
repositions to D3
yeah another
misplaced Arrow uh but you know this
might buy black some time keep preserve
the bishop I think it's important for
black to preserve this bishop because
well it's the king's Indian Bishop it's
going to be doing the attacking if White
Castle's uh Queen side
well I'm not so sure I mean looks like
it should be but if uh let's say if the
Bishops being traded then you got all
these dark squares like Queen B6
C8 and you allow Bishop G7 King G7 not
sure if this case that's dangerous but
then maybe you'll have F5 agree yeah F5
is actually very annoying
yeah I agree this March of the F Pawn
and that's part of the reason Vladimir
took with the with the Jeep on uh which
was a very good practical decision
and we see a move
and Mr Carlson
has gone it's knocking H7 I can still
see his King on G8
maybe some Bishop D7
we're about to find out drumroll
no not the bishop d c takes D5 oh cd5
cd5 okay
okay we've had it capture on D5 capture
on D5
which makes sense I mean you got to open
up the queen side
yeah maybe bishop B7 then
drug C8 just to quickly develop the
queen size pieces
yeah
and I agree I think Magnus doesn't care
as much about Bishop H6 this move kind
of signals that
he's fine with the bishop trade he wants
to get his pieces out
and um
he wants to open up the center again
with some move like he
well I don't know E5 just sacrifice a
pull and completely open up
yeah that's definitely not out of the
question
B6 Bishop B6 I mean that's in the spirit
of the king's Indian
for sure
well I'm not so sure it's after E5
you're not forced to take support you
probably can play the move like uh
Bishop E3
because then you can play with this D6
weakness I mean without detex E6 Oh you
mean immediately sorry yeah yeah I'm not
sure because now your opponent just
Blocks Your Bishop
yeah the bishop the bishop is terrible
and um I agree and I mean eventually you
can play Rook G1 Castle
and white can also play on The Queen
side in some of these positions like
Castle moved the king over and Rook C1
so
um all right yeah so so so this is
interesting but doesn't seem to solve
all of Black's problems
and um
we're gonna see what Magnus does he's
dipping a little bit on the clock I mean
remember this is move 12. he's got 51
minutes already in age seven uh-huh I
know your idea
well
um I can
when I'm sitting in my comfortable chair
I can seem to get some of magnus's moves
but
when he's sitting in front of me I'm
going down so yeah he wants to preserve
the bishop and Vladimir probably is
going to Castle long I would imagine or
maybe Rook q1 or your idea Bishop B3 at
some point could be interesting
yeah maybe just the castle along I guess
Castle long can be one we'll see
that's a worldwide should play sooner or
later
yeah
I don't know what photo save is going to
do here I think he's gonna Castle
uh just get on with it I mean of course
he could get ejaculated on the queen
side so there's a certain certain safety
net to remaining in the center it's not
so easy to get to White's King
uh when it's on E1
so
yeah no maybe you'll try just to quickly
create the king side attacks like Bishop
I mean drug G1 moving the bishop away F4
but that's just unlikely because black
will still started with some Bishop D7
B5 to create the counter play so I guess
the long Castle will available
right
yeah he just looked up at him like all
right game on Magnus
um
I'm not seeing yeah I'm not seeing any
super viable
other options
yeah I think long Castle is just going
to happen
as we see feta save contemplating
contemplating this move Magnus has
gotten up
he has gone away
who is his mask song
the sieve is looking up in the air
I really think he's deciding whether or
not to Castle I think that's
a crucial decision
well what else apart from long Castle
yeah I don't I don't see my I mean Rook
G1
it's to me the only the only other
viable viable option
just comparing to preparing to to do
something in the king side but I don't
really see much
yeah but then maybe just Bishop D7
and what if we try to keep the king in
the center and go like eight four
wow
Rook C8 I don't like it I'm just trying
to find other options because he's
thinking for a while
maybe you can even premiere
yeah I mean
who knows but we're gonna go on a quick
break as far as they have uh thinks
about his move we're gonna take this
chance to take a quick break I'm gonna
grab my coffee and uh well you're gonna
buckle your seat belts because we got a
pretty interesting position Brewing here
in the game between featherston and
Carlson we will be right back
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup and we have a very special
guest Grandmaster Jan Christoph Duda
vanquisher of the world champion Magnus
Carlson and today making a quick and
very comfortable draw with the black
pieces against Sergey karyakin in the
first game of the final the actual stuff
congratulations on uh an incredible
performance so far that feeling when
Magnus gives you his hand and resigns
what is that like that's that's that's
got to be an incredible feeling that
very few people have experienced
yeah hello everyone thank you Danny
um yeah that was very crazy uh
experience I mean to be honest I didn't
expect I can win with black against
Magnus especially taking into account
that I had always
I was always struggling against him like
I made half out of five I think prior to
that World Cup
so yeah I mean they didn't expect
honestly that one can leave black
[Music]
um
yeah no I was kind of you know surprised
and exhausted I even wasn't that happy
at the time I mean it didn't actually to
me at all and that time that I had just
qualified to final and candidates
um yeah I mean but obviously it was like
you know the moment
I've been waiting like you know all
right all my life
right
did was there a particular turning point
in the game yesterday we were uh we were
impressed Bishop B4 completely takes
this thing out of out of White's
position was there a moment that you
kind of mentally realized that you're
now fighting for the advantage of Magnus
is getting uncomfortable
yeah I'm not really sure
um okay Bishop before first of all was
just some random move I mean I just want
I just played it quickly I didn't see
honestly uh
the idea of trading industry Bishops
here but I am like
um I have like less space so I guess it
makes sense to trade pieces
obviously he went ambitious I mean
didn't write those Bishops and yeah I'm
not really sure where
when when I like took over in that game
um but actually the good thing is that I
sense The Denture quite quickly because
[Music]
I mean it looked pretty harmless I think
to me but I understood that he wants to
play this H4 G3
yeah possibly followed by 95 at some
point or even like H5 H6 typical Alpha
zero stuff
um yeah and I think I did reasonably
well like uh
at least I mean I got rid of his Queen
from D3 when it was like perfect
and yeah and before it was controversial
move I guess I mean obviously it was
ambitious but also like very risky for
him now and around here I felt I'm in
very good spot
and yeah but I didn't like what I did uh
like playing this I mean I got stuck
with Queen on C4 yeah that probably
didn't make that much sense
possibly I should have played like Queen
A6 instead of Queen C4 because now I
mean there is no progress whatsoever
I mean very difficult also the 360
Bishop d8 Bishop B6 tab is very cool you
know but I'm not sure it's like
anything great for me to be honest
yeah and here obviously yeah here
obviously there were some moments that
uh he could have defended better as
computer indicates
um I mean I also didn't see a lot I mean
in this moment queen of one Rook D1 was
the idea I guess also there was like a
shortcut move a bit later Rook C5 in
some position I don't remember when he
took on C6 I guess
outside immediately I don't know how
Magnus could have missed it yeah I also
miss it to be honest like
um yeah no that would
have been extremely unpleasant of course
for me because it radically changes the
nature of the position and it's actually
a free game I mean I mean it feels out
it's game so yeah Rook C5 was have been
like
extremely difficult to cope with yeah
and after Rook 86
um
yeah okay I don't know what's the
position but that means this is crazy
and not I mean because okay here just
context that one was probably winning
the spot I
I don't know why they didn't take it I
mean I know because I didn't want to
allow this rookie Rook bi stuff because
Queen takes the one king takes F1 looks
A3 and so on but I mean it was
completely winning for black
um
looking safely
yeah and there is nothing yeah it looks
eight King H7 effort B8 but even Rook B3
I guess followed by rupees before it's
okay yeah I mean yeah sometimes you do
like strange things
um yeah that was one of those moments
and no I mean I played okay maybe
okayish obviously not perfect but
I was very upset with uh playing dxd4 I
mean
because here Bishop d8 is very
sophisticated like I forced him to play
G5 and now now the end game is like
totally winning for me after once he has
committed himself to playing G5 because
I have King Gates and King V6 idea and I
mean it's just another weakness for
white
yeah but actually dtext C4 was kind of
like total nonsense in given situation
obviously I wanted to take with Rook
but I mean I just you know stop at
school you know just winning slowly I
mean King 87 King D6 Bishop B6 not
allowing any country play like totally
winning uh yeah and I played DC4 which
is obvious which is also good but I mean
it complicates the game and here I
didn't take an A3 for some reason like I
don't know Rook D5 look see I was afraid
of some counter play but after root C5
but I mean it's probably just nothing
like no but you are when you are like
alone time I mean you don't really want
to allow any counter play and and I
thought that visual engine should also
be like easily winning for me because he
has like oh he spawned of course but
apparently it's this crazy idea with G6
and E6 yeah and obviously I blended from
G6 stuff yeah 46
you know and but then you readjust it
and you still manage to put pressure
which was so impressive yeah okay he
blanded yeah I mean he could have played
Bishop D4 instead of uh Bishop C1
later on no I mean here here it was like
extremely random I mean I'm playing for
a win obviously but I mean on 10 seconds
it's difficult because you have to like
calculate opponent games for example
um yeah but you don't really want to
trade those Bishops so yeah I mean very
now he was very nervous and it's
actually kind of miracle that he
blundered I mean I think he blundered
because he was like under pressure for a
long time nobody like cops well uh
I mean such situation but
and here is winning yeah I mean okay
after Bishop B2 Bishop 63 I was sure
that
I would win so yeah that was crazy game
um yeah yeah I mean okay
I mean my nature took advantage of me
and I had to like made it random at some
point because it was like two you know
too straightforward
um you kept the pressure yeah for so
long in this game
yeah that's that's true uh obviously the
idea was to like
to play I mean I mean to pressure with
white pieces but somehow he was capable
of dealing dealing with it pretty easily
so
yeah and also in the first game of Thai
black I got myself pins I mean I was it
was so like embarrassing and stupid I
mean to allow that I could have just
traded a thing and make an easy draw and
then put this pieces like in this
Square Queens Quincy 595 will be free
Bishop C3 yeah hopefully it was holding
but I mean
yeah sometimes when you are too
ambitious I mean such strange things can
happen yeah but obviously that was a big
game for me
and one can say more
um yeah very very pleased obviously if
we need this
it's an incredible achievement young
Kristoff and of course you have a very
tough final game
the candidates so a big congrats on that
were all very impressed with your plan
you're fun not to put words in your
mouth but I yesterday we were
uh we were we were really really
impressed with the level and the you
know the quality of your play but in
time pressure so we will let you uh eat
dinner and and rest young stuff but
thank you so much for appearing on our
broadcast it's an honor and uh
congratulations on making the candidates
good luck tomorrow again Sergey and uh
have a great have a great rest today
yeah thank you congratulations and a lot
for the final match
yeah thank you
and it's great to have young stuff in
our studio you find um he's very very
modest uh he's just incredibly humble
but
I mean defeating Magnus with black is
never a coincidence and he played
incredibly and there were mistakes there
were time scramble mistakes but that
doesn't detract at all from the fact
that he played an amazing game in my
opinion
yeah definitely I I was just about to
say that the games is in the tie breaks
are also in the very high quality I
doubt that even in the classical games
you know if anyone even the top players
who they have the same level I mean
and through his analysis in the last of
this m game also shows that he has some
very uh sophisticated ideas like this
okay moves from H7 G6 F5 it shows that
actually he knows exactly that what
happens on the board and just under the
time control you probably choosing
between the options and the decide to go
for another whatever in general that's
very impressive and uh feels like his
chest career also has a let's say to a
bright future
so extremely yeah he's already so
experienced and he's you know
he's very real right he is very young
he's with 20
21 22 I don't know exactly
but something like that
something like born around 99 or 2000
that this is still basically you know
starts your career I mean not as
professional transferable maybe as the
world the elite chess player
right yeah some players they they only
break into as you said they break into
Super GM status at that age dude has
already been there for a couple of years
and he plays with the with the maturity
level and when I see maturity I don't
literally mean obviously he doesn't make
impulsive moves I mean the guy is 27.50
live but there's a sense in which
he he knows all all of these structures
so well uh he's been there done that
he's not susceptible to the pressure in
the same way that some of the other
players are when they're facing Magnus
and he doesn't let Magnus do what he
wants he he's he's Egypt doesn't
cooperate with Magnus and he makes it
difficult for the world champion and we
can see the entire match Agnes was
uncomfortable and that's a pretty big
deal
when the world champion is made
uncomfortable like that several games in
a row
yeah definitely especially we shouldn't
forget that dude that's playing style is
okay correct me if I'm wrong it's very
similar to Magnus I mean he's also not
those type of very tactical rare uh
players who wants to create the chaotic
positions but he's very classical he's
very let's say uh understanding all the
theories so which we all know is a
superb ability of Magnus so they're
basically fighting against each other's
strong points so I guess that makes a
Magnus uncomfortable even meaning more
compared to those I I think Magnus also
has some tough match in the previous
rounds but some positions when that gets
into those super complicated ones it's
uh it's easier that you're feeling
uncomfortable but it's not like every
time you can you can get or create those
type of chances so I guess that's even
more showing his let's say overall
ability
for sure
um I think that's a great
characterization
and um yeah they do have you know due to
strong points
are structured in a way that that
doesn't make it easy for Magnus
and uh in the FedEx game well Magnus
isn't easy he hasn't seemed happy since
move three and he still doesn't seem
happy he's below 45 minutes now
what is Vladimir done Vladimir played A4
so like your idea again Daniel so it'll
be there flying because you
noticed and the pre-anticipated both the
blacks play and the white plan kh7 the
A4 A5
well I mean the idea of keeping the king
in the center is uh you know it stems
from the notion that it's just hard to
get to the king
um a lot harder than epic castles now
Magnus is trying to get his Knight to C5
but
I think here there's this move Bishop D1
that's very commonly played
defending okay the eval bar hated that
move
I guess there's maybe some better way to
defend against 93 Rook A3 who knows
story seems like a good move as you also
protected the C3 Knight preparing for B4
indeed and
white would basically be asking black
the question how are you going to
develop your play on The Queen side
because White's starting to squeeze
black
quite a lot here Rook G1 these old ideas
are still very much prevalent here
yeah so I was just wondering whether
this night manure with Knight to D7 is
happening at the right moment
I think Magnus is asking himself the
same question here
and he doesn't have too much time to ask
it anymore
he spent too much time to be honest
maybe he's not talking about a starring
game I mean it could be
thinking about why he didn't draw that
end game against younger stuff and
yeah
very unprofessional but sometimes you
know uh players might get into those
type of situations I don't know Daniel
have you uh experienced something you
like that 100 and you can't help it in
some moments you just can't help you
know it's as you said unprofessional
you're not you've got to put it behind
you all the cliches but you just can't
it's like a loose you know it's like
when your tooth falls out and it's like
your tongue goes to that spot it's like
you just keep on replaying it in your
mind like man if I'd only made that one
move
um the entire situation would have been
different
and I've lost some games because of that
even if you're partially concentrated on
the current game you're constantly
jumping back to to the bad memory of the
previous game and it clouds your
judgment it makes you less objective
um I'm not saying Magnus is doing that
but it's got to be playing a role he
just doesn't seem the same right now
yeah
too much time is starting from moves
free
yeah and he continues to struggle in
this position the engine clearly doesn't
seem to think anything is anything is
uh nothing is the issue
um but I think the reality on the ground
is is quite unpleasant for black
maybe Knight to E5 then Bishop d7ox C8
and I'd probably go here
um he's made a move he played F5 wow
that's pretty bold
I was thinking about that but
didn't know what to make of it after he
takes F5
you better say I'm surprised
I'm also surprised to be honest because
I feel like it's completely weakened
upon G6 so
yeah risky
I think I understand his idea
I think he wants EF5
and if Rook at five I was thinking
Bishop D3
or even Knight C5 some some version of
The Exchange sacrifice
maybe not like this maybe maybe 95.
well
actually this isn't even a sacrifice
okay this is
yeah this is this is not even
sacrificing anything because you can't
take the rook and if you take the Knight
then black will take with the Rook so
that has to be a lot more careful than
that I suppose
maybe white should I keep
yeah accumulate
because if you play 95 here we might
take the night and the place between oh
no that's not good because you can play
detex E5
G5 but then you can take this point
but even here after Queen G5
I feel like after Rook GA black is fine
uh yeah right I was thinking something
like yeah
no that's a cool idea but it's just one
tempo
Gonna Save just like looking at oh no I
thought it was looking at Madness
but um yeah so Rook G1 is is definitely
a pretty serious candidate move
all right he takes F5 still has to be
considered just after Rook F5 there must
be some Alternatives
94.90 G5
oh
the nasty little sequence
I guess black and go Knight F6
cat five G8
Bishop D3
oh
I said I take the pawn you go Bishop C4
yeah I'm going to sack the exchange one
way or another but I'm probably going to
end up with not enough that night is
really really strong on G5 yeah that
really even helps you to Castle short
and play King G2 safely and Bishop G3
the keys actually say when the keys save
the exposition will be collapsed due to
your poorly pump structure yeah yeah I
agree um
yeah your gasoline sure don't rule that
out in certain situations the king will
be safest on the king side so
um Magnus has to factor that in
yeah so EF and 94 is another possibility
but I don't think that looks as good as
Eric G1 but the point is
after five when you think about uh the
continuation and after gy you literally
uh stop the possibility of short castle
that's another bad word
it's very committal
um you you want to be able to Castle as
you said
you know in case in case like for
example sacks The Exchange
yeah I didn't realize this before but
after the line we have just an analysis
is 90 for 90 G5 this shows the
importance of short Castle
right it's the best best place to be for
White's king
um if the Center opens up
um
yeah I wonder Rook G1 E6 F5 what else
exists well the bishop on F4 could move
back
but I don't love it
they shall be used three at home maybe
this is this is reasonable
95.
yeah and I was thinking okay gonna F4
there's Knight G4
I don't know
Rook G1
yeah no this gets a little bit dangerous
for white
uh once black plays f8 this movie five
it's
I think it's a lot better than it looks
maybe it looks good to people I don't
know it but it looks very weakening but
uh this is the King's Indian in Blacks
pieces have a ton of potential energy
and
Magnus is
able to realize it with that move
so let's see
how is Mr ferisev
going to handle this he's below an hour
like the first time in his chest cover
Yeah the more we look this e590 for
might be an option
seriously
yeah maybe after 90 for the play Knight
E5
so I'll probably give you a check
where King G8 okay
or maybe h8 but my idea was now to drop
the bishop back now that F3 is protected
and then prepare F4
oh
and I feel like this gets a little bit
unpleasant yeah maybe then we should try
Knight C5 because I was choosing between
those two squares for the Black Knight
C5
yeah now you're threatening of course
there's Knight P3 in fact if Rook G5 you
can play if Knight G5 you can play Rook
G5 and ip3
yeah oh wait but there's HG 93.3
beautiful
it takes a one
okay
this looks crushing yeah this is winning
so
apparently black has to move here that
holds things together maybe it's Queen
f8 I don't know
are you me here but I couldn't even
defense the email bar is not showing as
overwhelming of an advantage as I would
think given this
then
five probably oh that's kind of cool
takes and if white blindly goes for this
line black is winning with the bishop F5
and the queen is literally just trapped
yeah you have to suck the rock then not
enough compensation well there's still
in line like a rocket shade king h8
queen H5 King G8 G6 but they were like
chocolate
yeah black can start going after because
they're Knight C2 Bishop G6 98
that's symmetry key
the garbage of these three
right maybe I can go here
ah because I thought Queen H7 Bishop H6
yeah and queen G6
checked King F7 and somehow black
escapes oh over
I think Philadelphia might be
calculating stuff like this I know we've
gone very far but
oh Rook he's gonna move
wow these moves are quite hard to
predict Rook C1 I guess he just wants to
improve his position and he basically
says all right Magnus well
you might play F5 that's all well and
good but you're not threatening anything
so I'm going to take this opportunity to
improve my position
wait a minute not afraid of Queen A5 he
played okay
okay success against Knight C5
this is a very
genius idea
yeah this is this is cool
and again it should be very important to
point out that
um that he's the idea of castling long
here is no longer viable once you first
Define so it's not like he's Burning
Bridges by going Rook A3
he's solidifying its position Knight C5
will no longer threaten a fourth this is
what you were indicating if on and
he's tossing the ball right back into
magnus's court so I guess Knight E5 is
the most natural move here
correct
and then but then white can go about his
business with Rook G1 I guess
this is probably what fetus said once
and the email bar hates me today
almost move the bishop away because in
that case I think you still get noise E4
so maybe some move like Bishop
well I was hesitated to go to move like
Bishop G's trivia that's super
weird
but this position is quite irrational
it's a lot there's so much going on and
it might not seem that sharp when you
just look at it but the possibility of
everything exploding is incredibly High
both Kings can get checkmated in the
long run here
just to reiterate
um just to reiterate Rook A3 what
exactly is the idea well black has this
idea of going sc5 and then threatening a
fork
The Rook A3 is a prophylactic move
against that but it's not just that it
also solidifies White's position it
defends the Knight maybe white will want
to play before at some point
so it's a typical move in certain kinds
of these positions
which is what I would say
and maybe yeah who knows maybe later The
Rook will swing to G3 and some alternate
reality
so it's a good prophylaxis move and it
keeps all the possibility we discuss the
short Castle Rock G1 Bishop to different
places but the only problem is whether
this could be a little bit slow
right
so for example after Knight E5 what's
the plan for white still unclear
yeah I agree I mean I think Knight E5 is
going to be played I don't see any other
moves for black foreign
I just don't see any other moves for
black
and if I were magnesite I'd play 95
quickly I just do it
because 38 minutes it'll do the same
his hand almost touches the mind okay
yep and uh yeah there's just no choice
whether it's good or bad it doesn't
matter you gotta go for it
I quite like F5 though I think it
changes the nature of the position black
was sliding into
let's just say black was sliding into a
dubious situation now I feel like the
position has really sharpened up
apparently it's dynamically equal both
sides of chances here yeah three results
position for sure oh yeah oh yeah
and fedesev excels in these positions
knowing Vladimir for so many years
he loves positions like this irrational
Sharp
room for creativity
the only problem is he's facing some
some guy named Magnus who
you know who might have something to say
about that so
so what what yeah the question of what
to do here is
is pretty hard to answer because you
were suggesting Bishop Bishop moving
Bishop G3 Bishop E3
yeah I was thinking to move this bishop
away
uh but which side because if you go the
E file
then it's unlikely you'll do the short
Castle
that's true but I still like Bishop E3
from the perspective of getting the
bishop out of the danger zone in case
black plays F takes E4
in fact here you can take with the nine
you can take with the Knight
because Knight F3 doesn't work white
takes and delivers a fork on G5 at the
end of the line
I think fataseva is going to ship E3 I'm
going to make another prediction here
okay today all your prediction came true
so maybe you should make predict
predictions it's about to move let's see
if it's Bishop B3 uh well Bishop B3 is
also not such a difficult move okay
Bishop E3 wow
accuracy precision yeah well the ones
the one I'm most proud of those C4 and
the Shanklin die break
but okay I'm making myself look good but
obviously it's it's a pretty
straightforward move so there's nothing
there's nothing special who might win
this game
oh gosh now you're really putting the
heat on
exposing the fraud that's my predictions
oh that's hard than the moves
the Magnus thinking
what to do for black here we were
discussing f64 are there alternatives to
that
um
Bishop D7
yeah
why not exactly and then Rook C8 I mean
I I like that
that's a pretty Magnus that's a pretty
magnus-like mode Bishop D7
Magnus likes to keep the tension he
doesn't like to
clearly clarify yep
thinking of the same word
he keeps things complicated
and he fences very well when the
opponent is losing the threat of the
game
so he's able to build up build up build
up the tension
so with white seriously contemplating
maybe F4
Knight G4 Bishop D4
you think of this
if taking on e4
not sake
and then maybe this will become a
reality The Rook swinging to G3
yeah suddenly this July story became a
great move so maybe I shouldn't take on
e4
still keeps attention play some move
like Roxy no but that I was worried they
could push E5 as some
moments the associate here
yeah
maybe click on G7 replacement E5
yeah and then or queen D4 and E5 and if
de your idea was Ivan Fe
yeah because of 95 there's Queen D4
pinning the Knight and then F4 winning
the night
Magnus continues to look pretty unhappy
here
the way this game is going
as she contemplates
what to do after Bishop E3
you just again I don't want to over
overuse the body language because you
never know but someone's actually
thinking but
it's hard not to not to conjecture on
the yeah how about the crazy idea like
E6
I don't think this could be a move but
just a choice
completely open up I like it I like an
idea like E6 because white is
structurally very weak
and this acts as an antidote also to
have four because now the situation kind
of collapses for white a little bit
and it's a funny stat that in all three
lifetime games between
better Sam and Carlson the world
champion played Black I wonder how they
did
okay so a move has been played
seems like it's what is that F4 or four
wow
you once with this you want to sack oh
does he want to sack on that four and go
Bishop H6 and queen f8
oh that's a really cool idea if that's
the case
that is amazing so Rook takes up and I
don't know if Rook takes up for us is
actual intention
but I was thinking of doing something
like straight out of a Soviet positional
chess textbook like exchange degree
flies and then get control of dark
squares uh Bishop comes to F4 and look
at this dark Square domination the black
has now black is sacked in exchanging
upon this is no laughing matter I would
not put much stock in the eval bar here
I like Black's position
yeah me too the same this F4 is
brilliant
or else we've already gathered stats
that uh Carlson is leading in their
three previous games
but I forgot to check the exact scores
yeah two to one I think we they flashed
on the screen
uh Carlson's leading
all right Carson leads to say two to one
including two draws and one win the F4
is a great move but just amazing feather
stuff missed this one
yeah well I saw the possibility of it
for but sort of ruled it out after I
said okay just Bishop takes F4 but maybe
the exchange stack is not even forced I
mean you don't have to sack on F4 just
the fact that black is stacked upon
means that the bishop can't really move
because F3 will fall
and also we do not have the square E4
for the knights the Napoleon info could
be a bad hole that blocks the pieces
also G6 is safe here
maybe it goes on move like Queen a to
Queen F7
here
yeah
we need Quinn F7
and
okay for this day was taken we're about
to see Magnus might just take on it for
instantly we'll see
Bishop takes F4 plane
all right and the Moment of Truth Rook
takes up four would be amazing to see
and it might be the case that in that
resulting position it's just not that
not that amazing
but we'll see and as Magnus considers
The Exchange sacrifice and whether to do
it we are going to take this opportunity
to go on a quick break we'll keep the
cameras rolling on the world champion so
you'll be able to see when he plays the
move we'll be back in a couple minutes
with more of magnus's third place match
against Vladimir fedesif don't go
anywhere
[Music]
foreign
Worlds Cup and we already have one game
in the books if you're just joining us
the uh first place matchup between
yanchus abdura and Sergey kayakin uh
ended in a relatively peaceful and well
very peaceful and very quick draw
um Duda was black it was another Vienna
uh kayaking repeating magnus's opening
choice
deviating this time with this move Queen
A4 check followed by Knight E5 and
interesting attempt but Jan was
incredibly prepared for this as well his
openings have been astoundingly well
developed nothing seems to surprise him
Rook be it is amazing and after Knight
C6 BC they all are following
uh another Duda game Rook D1 is the
deviation and you find neither of us was
really impressed with this move and it
just seems like it didn't produce much
after Bishop G5 Bishop B7 or yakin ends
up basically offering a draw with Queen
takes A7
yeah same to life
he's preparing for a drawer today I mean
not preparing but not the list is more
than acceptable
right and after Queen B7 Rook B8 the
queen is unable to escape
the uh persistent attacks of the rook
and so we have a three-time repetition
and a drawn of course
um those people who are aware of the 30
move no draw rule of course
um
to remove repetition circumvents that
you can repeat three times and make a
draw that way
uh so that is that remains a viable
method of making a drop
okay so that is drawn tomorrow of course
will be game two with uh yeah I'm just
not being white
against karyakan we still have one game
going on the third place matchup between
Carlson and ferisev
with the world champion Bishop D7
deciding against sacking on F4
and instead simply developing well maybe
you'll have four years at his hand so he
can do any time he wants so basically F4
move is uh is is to avoid any wise F4 so
just to fix this structure and forcing
white from attacking position switch to
the defending positions we can say let's
move 91 91.
so for the save opening up sort of the
third rank for the Rook
and reinforcing his defense on the F3
Pawn he wants to move the bishop away
from F4 now so if Carlson wants to sack
The Exchange now's the time to do it
yeah otherwise you will let this bishop
go that F4 probably wouldn't be
um not very meaningful
I would suck
I mean I'm very biased obviously
oh well that's typical cannot say that
especially this night on D1 that cannot
goes to E2 to support the F4 square but
probably he'll got this 90 390 G2 one
day
right
and um
Rook up four Queen F4 so compared to the
other version where this was possible
Queen f8 I queen f8 is very important I
think because F4 is is a big threat and
that on unblocks blocks control over the
dark squares and Magnus has taken on F4
and he's done it
according to their hand moves over the
board seems like it's okay for them
Bishop H6 yep we see it reflected on the
board
I guess we'll see Queen G3 queen of
fights but the point is uh
what's next
yeah I mean I think it's a lovely
sacrifice it's it's not out of the realm
of of it's not typical but it's you know
it's it is a this idea does exist in the
king's India the dark Square control
and uh some really really nice classical
games have been won with these kinds of
sacrifices where you get and the way I
think people should understand this it's
I look at this but I don't understand
like what is life threatening it's less
about black having a specific threat
here and more about domination over a
set of squares like if you look at the
dark squares they're totally under black
control makes it very hard for white to
to break free and eventually Black's
going to start accumulating the pressure
on Queen F6 Rook f8 so black is going
for the long-term play here it's nothing
in the short term that's going to result
in Checkmate you know
you know okay my question here is
whether white well play this move F4
yeah
point to the other side I mean it's
doubtful because you lose one of the F
pawns along the field
even provoke this attacks along that
file so the only purpose is trying to
activate the queen
yeah I think black is I would take black
here I completely disagree with the evil
bar which shows only a slight Advantage
for white but I I categorically disagree
I think black has full compensation
black is definitely not better here
I don't think black can be better down
in exchange in the pond but uh but
practically speaking the compensation is
excellent I don't know if you agree with
that if I maybe I'm overstating the
effectiveness of this
no I can't say that again because I also
felt like the compensation is here due
to the structure and the dark Square
Bishop wouldn't be less valuable
compared to the Rook right but I know
even more is this Queen's battle employs
because if you if we can bring the queen
to somewhere like D4 I might prefer
white to be honest about this queen G3
where to go if you go to G2 then this 9
is bad
if you go to Gua I doubt it would be a
move to be honest the queen LG Virgo H1
quickly imagine that unless you could
move the bishop somewhere else and the
place of King E2 but it's just hard to
coordinate
right it is very hard to court it's
crazy hard to coordinate the queen is
fully sectioned off
and despite magnus's disappointing
result yesterday he seems to be
it seems that there's been a transition
he's put it behind him as we take a
quick look at that tweet I had
referenced unforgiving indeed huge
congrats to JKD and protagon for making
the finals candidates losing today
certainly hurts well this was yesterday
of course but I'm nevertheless happy
with my progress in the tournament and
also getting great practice Yeah right
Max Facts was very thrilled yesterday
I'm sure he was in his hotel room
smiling yeah great great progress but of
course very gracious and I'm just uh
giving him a hard time Magnus uh always
always quick to congratulate his
opponents and um
and today it just seems like he might
have been disappointed at first but but
he's he's pushed it behind him and now
he seems to be returning to his old form
yeah all right I guess no he probably
would be happy for his position
first time in the day
right
and you know in hindsight and in 2020
hindsight
it might turn out that maybe bishop B3
was not quite right
I wonder where I think Rook A3 is fun
I'm gonna put it this way
oh and it continues also playing for
Agnes that wasn't enough Magnus followed
up also playing for third is my new jam
so I don't really mind that uh
sunglass emote
um at the beach
yeah yeah yeah all right all right
Magnus that's typical Magnus by the way
I mean I was saying like this about just
a sense of humor in this way
oh yeah and and that's what we like I
think that's what we love about him you
know world champion he's serious when he
needs to be but uh there's nothing wrong
with being funny
um and uh after after the the battle is
over there's nothing wrong with uh
it's having a laugh about it I think
people need to do more of that
so it's great to see that Magnus has a
sense of humor and you know he engages
in some of these very friendly ribbing
contests on Twitter on Twitter and on
Twitch
uh it's awesome I personally find that
to be
um humanizing and and and great
and AC is always professional when he
needs to be so
um I I think positively of that but
maybe Rook A3 was was the start of the
the movement in the wrong direction you
called it if I think it's a little bit
too slow this move it gives black a
chance to bring his visas into the right
squares
and now
this is the position on the board
all right
so what does try to save do
because you know he already realized
there's a threat but he still plays the
move Knight to D1 so I was just
wondering because I don't think this
night should be placed on D1 if black
did the exchange one move earlier so
oh
so 93 Bishop F4
Queen G2 how is black going to improve
his position Rook C8 Rook C8 yeah
we can White Castle yeah white can still
Castle right
oh okay I was just testing I was just
trying to remember if White had moved to
see of course why does not move to King
okay Castle queen of six
yeah I agree no this is a classic
example of from the frying pan Into the
Fire you wouldn't like to go Queen H1
and even may have some Rook G8 G5 in the
future
oh gosh
yeah no now E1 seems like the safest
Square in the world in comparison to
that but the problem is if you go Rook
C3 black could even take it and go Queen
d8 and start yeah zipping up those pawns
on A5 and C3
I think I'm Gonna Save My maybe go Rook
C3 I don't know
we'll see he's about to make a move you
can see his hand on the table Yeah Rook
say three is making sense
yep
let's see and then the question for
black is whether he need he will do the
exchange on the C file
normally we shouldn't do when we our
material down but here the case is the
H1 neural country to Queen is way more
or less active so maybe that makes the
changing opponent active pieces
reasonable
right
E3
and I'm going to predict that we
probably will see that position on the
board I mean Bishop F4 is kind of
irresistible
uh-huh
and after
93 and we're just gonna wait for that
movement how about the queen G1 King D2
it sounds crazy but
no I mean it makes a lot of sense
um okay sometimes it's on time
they also feels very tricky after Bishop
F4
so Queen G I'm in que LG 2k2 I thought
Queen oh you were thinking Queen she won
King D2 and try to send the queen around
yeah well maybe I should bring the rock
out
right both options seem to make sense so
King D2 I think that's really
interesting because if you can get all
your pieces out like this
you know everything will finally be back
in the game
but obviously it is scary
it is a scary thing to go for
this should be five here is an
interesting try
between B1
hmm
wow there's so many tactics I could I
could stare at this position for an hour
right there
wrap my head around
the complexities
I mean some sort of calm move like Queen
F6 also comes to mind
so probably not good just Bishop takes
bishop and just one check
yeah I don't know what black should do
here
um because you're eventually gonna
you're gonna play Rook C1 on the next
move you can't get two Cavalier with
black you're gonna end up just down and
exchanging some end game
so Magnus has to operate with a sense of
urgency
ah
okay so I'm expecting Bishop F4 do you
see a point in delaying that move
uh well Rook C8 first because Bishop F4
is at your hand
well the problem is you need to watch
out of 93 2.
yeah here probably it doesn't work
because of Rook D1 but I agree in
general it's a threat
maybe here there's Rook C3 but then
thanks thanks Bishop F4 then Queen d8
and we're back to that line
position
after Queen A5 to play Queen A1
it's about to play Bishop F4 I think
yeah yeah that's a cool idea Queen G1
here
and
okay in the event of black and also Play
Bishop E3 Knight F3 but queen d8 king D2
and white could end up being better in a
situation like this
because everything is defended
and black is an uncomfortable spot it's
not clear how to avoid the queen maybe
Queen C5 but
yeah yeah this is not not the way you
probably still can create some Fortress
but already
white is away from the dangerous
situation right only white is flank for
an edge it seems okay so let's let's see
what Magnus ends up doing he's got 30
minutes
he's he's accelerated his Pace to play a
little bit in the last couple moves
which I think is important
board
logical and nothing option where do you
move the queen I guess G2 because gyr
looks like
super scary
right you've got to think about it
though and
the thing with playing Magnus I guess is
that you should be you should try to be
as aware as possible of these of these
nuances
uh because they could they could decide
the game and okay but a save is gonna
play too quickly
okay so then after Rook C8 I guess it
will be moved
and still King D2 is is possible I think
the rooksia Rook C3 line might occur on
the board Rook C3 takes takes Queen d8
but let's say if castles we might see
that kind of situation
all right and then doing the short
Castle making sense right because then
then sure castling seems quite a bit
safer
all right
the queen G2
and it's black to play
so other than Rook C8
are there options I I don't see too much
else I guess queen of six is also
possible
is it we have six
okay well Roxy's right here
and then I was thinking of yeah Rook GA
and G5 but it's it's not good yeah well
what all together screen
right exactly at the right moment and
this only benefits white to open the H
file it's kind of Madness actually
and yeah
so Queen G2
Hindi too
oh wow
just straight away
yeah I was thinking first like Queen F6
but maybe they've got Rook C3
right Queen F6 Rook C3 you basically
wait I'm sorry
you basically wait for white for black
to misplace the queen and then you've
got Rook C3 and white is definitely
better here
King D2 is a pretty testing move
basically asked black the question okay
your position looks great but
how are you going to make any specific
improvements
yeah
okay but the question here whether
yeah it's that old move and
that might open the center enough to to
create more chances for black
yeah E6 I like I like the movie six and
let's say I play
oops C1
and I guess
you can take on D5
click on D5
and black has opened up some
parts of the position but still after a
rook trade I find it hard to believe
that
you know white is in any in two series
of danger
yeah because after this e-point exchange
the white might even get Bishop D1
Bishop C2 in the future
um that's a cool maneuver don't forget
about that pond being weak
it's really not sure if this E6 opens
the file I mean opens the lines for home
safely Magnus is he's thinking he's
taking a while here
I guess there's another candidate move
the immediate E6 also comes to mind
but it doesn't do as much with the King
not on D2 because Edie there will be
Knight to five yeah E6 may be just the
Roxy's right
next move
yeah exactly if black doesn't play over
C8 yeah
and even if he does it'll be possible
so I really wonder what other candidate
move is attracting
magnus's attention
sip of his water he seems pretty
satisfied there's a sense in which
you know there was a turning point when
Magnus plays F4
but um I still believe that black is
full comp but
I'm amending my assessment a little bit
I feel like
you know if anything could happen three
results are possible in the next couple
of moves I think are going to determine
who's playing for a win
both sides have to be very precise
how about Queen F6 0x63 then B5
B5
interesting
yeah and if I play King did you you want
the C4 Square as an anchor Point
potentially or B or of course before
yeah before moving the night away open
up this diagonal right
oh
that's a that's an interesting idea as
well
I can move my king to D1
um
but I don't know but then before
yeah this is not an impressive movement
it's not so easy for white to to find a
the next Improvement because that Queen
on F6 disawades well what castling is
bad not even because of Queen H4 I think
but because of your idea Rook G8
and G5 to follow
yeah and that just might be winning I
don't think storage Castle would be an
option in most of the cases even if you
exchange The Rook because
this King on the G1 is always at the
dangerous spot
yeah so this queen F6 Concepts giving up
the C file but preserving
more flexible let's just say attacking
chances
is being seriously contemplated by
Magnus I should I I would think he'd
make a move in the next two three
minutes because if you drop below 20
minutes for 18 moves I mean
you're basically playing
like a rapid game
um or even one good sale Mr Blitz game
and this is not the kind of position you
want to be in time pressure at
yeah at first I thought black is uh you
know having a very comfortable one but
now not that sure but still feels like
white is
more tough to deal with this position
over the board maybe that's also the
reason why feathers have trying to keep
the time pressure because the last
couple of moves they play relatively
fast
right
and he always has a Time advantage that
can't be underestimated
I can't be underestimated uh when you
when you consider what a strengths are
it's absolutely something that should
enter the portfolio you know or the
dossier
so he goes for the movie initially
thought and
big choice for Vladimir King D2 versus
Rook C3
and I'm I'm gonna predict that this Rook
C3 takes takes Queen d8 happens
oh okay you know Vladimir well I was
thinking King D2 looks more likely well
fine
you're probably right
I think the longer blimer thinks that
the likelier it is of like King D2
because Rook C3 to me is the instinctual
move you know okay black puts a rook on
the C file so should we but King D2 is
the more
um is the deeper move because you
understand that there is no immediate
urgency to playing Rook C3 you would
rather do it in a better version
with the other Rock
but I was just thinking after King D2
Rook C1 so for example black plays Queen
F6 if you go Roxy one do the exchange
taking on H4 and get rely on this H Pawn
push to h3h2
like yeah you have six I don't know but
uh also the possibility why it should
consider
yeah definitely a danger like uh yeah
even if the Rooks traded as you're
saying if the H4 font is gone black is
Max Pawn is the red carpet rollout
right all the way to H2
yeah it felt like a black should be in
charge of the game
right people the petrogen would be so
happy to have this with black
yeah but the homework I'll be happy for
whites unlikely porch night Fortune I
would be happy to have this right oh
really Grabber of material I think Court
should know at least in the sort of
Russian sphere has a reputation as being
um sort of a grabber of material
um and
yeah there's like a Russian you know
saying like cartoon when anything was
offered in material he'd take it first
and think later so and that's true to an
extent I think Court snow was a very
that's what made him hard to play he
he was never
um
he never trusted his opponent he he
called a lot of blood now he lost a lot
of games because of that but
um I think that's that's where the
reputation came from
but I okay
it's nowadays it's not like you can call
there's no really such thing as like a
super shame as a particularly greedy
player players have Universal Styles
they
they take material when they need to and
um being overly materialistic doesn't
get you far
yeah I thought I'd point out a very good
point like a universal player not only
in this end that's it aspect of taking
material or sacrifice but also for the
opening and the playing style as well
it's unlikely to see that someone who's
super good at which one side but lacking
of uh Disney skills on the other side
right that that's true and it's not that
players in let's say the 60s and 70s
didn't try to be Universal they nobody
tried to have weaknesses but because you
could play a much more narrow opening
repertoire as you're indicating
uh it was a lot easier to mask
uh some of the some of the less stronger
points in your game and it's not like
again GMS had huge gaping holes in their
game it's just that
you know there are certain positions
that top players wouldn't understand as
much
as others and nowadays it's
you know that's still true to an extent
but to a much lesser extent than before
yeah
all right so the technology developments
because otherwise most of the players
cannot be in the same level as they are
today
oh yeah absolutely
computers access to resources the
ability to analyze far greater
quantities and
um
yeah lots of hesitation today sort of
raising the hand and
no I wasn't planning to make a move I
was you know you know
take care of an itch or something
but I think he's about to
play something and I and it's going to
be either
oopsy throw King D2 Castle is short
we kind of ruled out because of Queen F6
but
obviously it's not impossible to make a
case for that if it is safe sees
something concrete there
uh he made short Castle because I think
I got some delay I didn't see any move
yet
no no he's still thinking I'm just
saying that
maybe he's also contemplating that
but we were we were skeptical of that
move
man let's see
decides to continue thinking
and um as he continues thinking we
wasting no time will go on a short break
things are heating up between Vladimir
fetus and Magnus Carlson it's a
fascinating position
um and I think the the rest of the game
is going to bring us a lot of action and
entertainment so don't go anywhere we've
been back in just a few watching the
finals of the fide World up the third
place match between Carlson FedEx we'll
be right back
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup
and we're watching Carlson play better
save those of you just joining you might
be wondering why are we focused only on
this game why are we not looking at the
final well that game is already over it
was over in 45 minutes
and it was a draw between Sergey who had
the white pieces in game one
great preparation by Duda and we won't
delve into the details again suffice it
to say that we had a pretty quick
repetition
and um both of them are going to uh rest
up and prepare for their game tomorrow
where young should stop was full of
confidence and has not lost the game
this tournament and he will have the
white pieces against Sergey but right
now we have the world champion trying to
rebound from his loss yesterday
and claim third place
fascinating position against Vladimir
fedes who has Ivan played Rook C3
Daniel again your predictions
well I I don't know if that's a good
thing though I think I liking D2 more so
um I'm also good at predicting bad moves
I suppose I mean that's basically the
only good thing I'm good at
no but that shows that while rook's
history objectively it's it's definitely
not a bad move and that shows you no
Fellowship very well
right and I think that yeah I don't know
what it is about Rook C3 that appeals to
me I just think it it when you're
playing Magnus
you know the risk is Amplified King D2
just there's something about that mode
that seems terrifying you know walking
into the pen
Rook C3 basically forces the trade of a
pair of Rooks which is unequivocally in
White's favor now obviously there's
confounding factors blacks White's pawns
become very weak
but at least black doesn't have a rook
to attack with and why can Castle short
yeah and maybe after Rook C3 BC Queen d8
there's an intermediate move like A6 and
then doing the short Castle
right
A6 ah just to try to disrupt the
coordination of black species first
so let's say 85 become important
B5 okay then maybe ba I don't know
the short Castle
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yep yep and I guess
Vin B6
oh
hard to suggest for white okay rook's
history has been played
yep I think this will happen take some
Queen d8
okay I think for the same is going to
take on C3 amazing prediction
Vladimir Fellowship he takes his teeth
he writes the move down will he take the
Rook buckle your seatbelts drum roll
please will you take on C3 will you take
on c3u going once going twice yeah he
takes in C3 and
um Magnus I think is going to react
pretty quickly here
are there alternatives to Queen d8 I
mean you could make a case for Queen F6
I guess just ignoring the pawns entirely
trying to dissuade white from castling
you mentioned this I think
uh not here
I guess it was before the H1 Rook yeah
because here Queen F6 King oh well I
love this oh yeah I can't think that too
I keep forgetting about that
keep forgetting that's possible
yeah so here Queen d8 I guess
I mean you're in too deep you have to go
for those Pawns
um
you could also
play Queen see it maybe but again you
need to
yeah and then Queen C5 so maybe Queen C
it is interesting
Queen C5 okay one
uh Bishop B5 something like that yeah
well maybe Rook B1 here foreign
yeah and this queen is coming through to
A2
that's bad
agreed this is rough
okay
um okay
so Mr Carlson is continuing to think
here yeah Queen C8 is somehow is
beginning to seem a little bit more
tempting to me than than before
foreign
yeah
unclear what to do here which of those
moves to play I still like black though
in both cases actually
and I should point out at this moment
that if you're watching the email bar
and you're seeing zeros don't do not
make the mistake of thinking this is
just a draw is there an evaluation of
equality does not mean
that this game is likelier to end in a
draw than in a white or black one it
just means that
you know the computer has determined
that both sides have dynamically
balanced chances may be
uh and in some crazy computer line the
game shouldn't under draw that doesn't
mean this position is drawn the two
different things
yeah definitely
so maybe Quincy it looks better
yeah I agree I think the C3 Pawn is the
key to the kingdom here
the key to the kingdom is that fun on C3
we'd see a plane
Queen C8 has been played so
and now Vladimir has to make another
decision does he play King D2 does he go
for that line oh C4 instantly
Queen C5 I guess
yeah and then Castle
yep
and queen A5 probably huh
and queen A5 and then try to return and
push that a pawn maybe that's the plan
I think only black will play for a win
here
I agree
just visually this seems like such such
a level of positional domination
it's surprising to me that you know the
computer doesn't seem to think that
black is better at all
but obviously that shouldn't be too
surprising given the material advantage
[Music]
and even Queen D2 oh that's very tough
for
White
Magnus is about to make a move
but we see a lot of this V5
look at that
why this move
wait what a fun passant
why not Quincy five
I know I mean there has to be
something going on here
that we missed I'm Poseidon happens
I guess there was something he didn't
like about Queen C5 but my question is I
happen to want to allow short Castle
because there's Bishop H3
oh oh that's cool that's so he wants to
keep his Queen here
or white
so that after castles the bishop H3 it's
a great great find
that's an incredible incredibly deep
concept and if white can't short Castle
well now B5 is again a threat because
you cannot allow the C file to open or
the King still anyone
oh
what makes Magnus Magnus
okay what does white do
because King F1 if you try to run this
way boom
okay
maybe we'll try short Castle Bishop H3
Queen H1 Bishop F1 bishop and four bite
the bullet yeah
yeah
we're not happy but at least it's it's
fine
so there's Knights G to what I'm
thinking about
that's hilarious but maybe we should
take back with the key one Quincy five
night G2 yeah yeah definitely a better
version
and now Queen C5
now Knight G2 becomes a serious idea
yeah because the poles are still in
favor of wine although it means nothing
at all
right
oh yeah well it is a football I
completely forgot about that
but you know the queen could come out to
H3 and E6
and potentially create
you know create the possibility
of some sort of attack you know I have
four out of five Flex dark Square
domination
Queen G1
he wants Knight sheets too but oh
terrifying how about the queen A8
whoa that was played very oh maybe he
wants King F1 King G2 also
oh that's clever it is clever but it
but it still looks terrifying
wait something's wrong with this move I
can feel it something's wrong with this
move
I can just it just doesn't smell right
maybe B5
what happens if B5 we have a funny
comment
uh in this chat
and Jesus commentary and makes me slack
off at work because oh God
thank you we are very happy to be um
essentially getting people fired and uh
you know
making the the world world economy
stuff because everybody's watching our
commentary it's our pleasure that's
that's why we do it
yeah definitely
well hope our commentary wouldn't really
influence the job right right now take
to take care of your work make sure that
make sure you know your boss is happy
and
only then watch our comments oh my
goodness I just spotted a crazy line
can I show you so B5 CB
5 is probably wrong but just just just
to demonstrate check check Knight C1
check King F1 and queen takes E2
what oh such
a brainiant Checkmate but it I
apparently B5 is wrong for some other
reason but if CB this is all porous
um
B5 maybe just can't I'm Gonna Cancel and
Bishop H3
yeah King everyone there's always this
check
King D2
allowing Knight C4 but then you take and
queen B1 I guess
okay so what but let's B5 is is far from
the only move I mean there's there's a
lot of Alternatives here
Queen
okay so if you go Queen C5 then you
allow this Escape vf1 you don't want to
allow that
foreign
okay Magnus is he's gonna have to move
soon he has not a lot of time 17 minutes
or so for 13 moves
well it's crucial he can spend 10
minutes here 14 moves
yeah yeah I agree like if he finds the
right move this might also be winning
yeah well I guess somehow he will play
B5
because
Queen A6 she wants
um but King F1 and then maybe Queen A2
ah
that kind of performances
nice
how's it taste though
takes a step of water let me let me get
hydrated first and then decide
I really like I thought it's very tricky
if you want to go Queen G1 why you go
Queen G2 at first
right and I don't like the speed with
which FedEx played that I guess he's
just trying to put the time pressure on
Magnus
but
but yeah he's
I think he's going Queen A6
I think F 1.82 trying to prevent you
know it's like holding on to the Jersey
stopping the king from completing the
Escape due to the bishop being on E2
yeah
why might just be losing that I guess
apparently it's the winning line
oh
I would even play Queen A8
yeah that's the same
but maybe Queen A6 there's some 65 crazy
C5 idea but okay but you can give a
check yeah yeah I mean that's Queen A1
check I guess it's ridiculous for white
all right Magnus is going to play Queen
A6 we are I'm confident with that
he was already about to grab his Queen
if he spots this idea of Queen A6 Queen
A2 it looks winning for black
therefore this B5 is a super strong
practical decision
is hesitating
nerve-wracking moment
15 minutes left
is probably praying he doesn't play
Queen A6
yeah maybe he missed some
idea
because after Queen
well maybe you don't like feed too
I guess it will be made it very soon
right
yeah there's too many
too many Avenues oh you're saying after
Queen a 292. yeah yeah after Queen two
knights G2
no that's fine it's fine oh that
actually is not so easy to refute
because Knight comes to E1 yes
that was a plan Ricky
mines
when I played
yeah I don't see anything off the top of
my head that ends the game immediately
um
when a 191
whole defensive idea here maybe just
night uh Knight C4 no the bishop is
saying
because if you go Bishop D2 why it will
have 93 again
right
and then shutting down the the gates
shutting down the bill
um Okay so
so maybe give a check
on
maybe A1 well I'll say the difference
and 91 of course and trying to play some
like B5
Aha and you want CB Bishop B5
yeah
wow that's that's really nice because
takes there's Knight takes F3 with
crushing threats
well you can go King G2
is even worse placed
so maybe
a knight C2
yeah and white somehow climbs out of the
Grave here and is able to bring the
pieces in time to at least
try to slow down the progress of the
pawn
all right and um
yeah but that must be have something
stronger
and we remind you of course if you want
to see
all of the games and look over all of
the moves chess.com slash events uh has
all of that in one spot all the results
very very convenient and you can watch
the current game
for example if you don't want to hear
our voice our voices and you're tired of
our commentary but you still want to
watch the game chess.com events
I mean of course you could also press
the mute button but we would never
advocate for that opening Explorer
you can do everything you want to do
of course this position has never
occurred before but
engine analysis all of the notation all
of the results on the right as you can
see with my cursor
everything in one place just.com events
all right so
Vladimir is thinking after Queen A8
and something tells me he's not going to
play quickly here
you might take or or maybe he will I
mean it's fair to say if he that's
exactly what he does he plays he plays
instantly in positions like these
watch him play King F1 like one second
oh my God I can't believe it the moment
I said it he played it
oh my goodness I mean there's really no
other moves
you know what so uh let's say if if this
game won by Madness and feather Seth
come back home and opened our commentary
right he would be like blame you like
aluminal messaging yeah
yeah now Queen A2 played by Magnuson and
Knight G2 I I completely I think
absolutely is the most tricky defense
yeah but maybe we missed something for a
black wait I have this feeling
like some move might have three Bishop
F3 Queen C4 Bishop e two please see 191
okay nothing
you were looking at nice C4
no I wasn't looking at the Knight F3 no
no three it doesn't work
doesn't work
okay well 15 minutes I mean Magnus has
to find something relatively quickly
and we were considering what we missed
maybe one and B5 was our initial idea
right your initial idea
uh yeah some tracks
of course no actually I said queen a1b5
that allows Knight C2 so maybe click on
B1 check then it was an accident I I
forgot
I guess probably the right move
yeah
yes it's actually very crucial
I think this is look at this position
it's just paralysis
win up one I guess has to be played
yeah
Magnus is going to see that I mean he's
so confident right now he's in a Zone
Queen B1 is about to be played
win A1 yeah you play Queen A1
wow
he played Queen A1
huh and that might be an inaccuracy
yeah maybe Queen B1 is stronger because
that follows you we shouldn't give the
C2 Square
but I've Rush that maybe Rush that a
little bit
and I wonder how how
much the eval changes Queen B2
huh
wait a second wait a second wait a
second
solid and quiet yeah
Knight G2 okay
okay so now he can repeat
and go Queen B1 B5
yeah Queen B1 and B5
well now because the Bishops yeah Bishop
is saying I mean there isn't too much
else that can happen Queen C1
91. careful Magnus don't repeat
this you want to just take on C4
huh
E5 looks great doesn't it I mean B5 has
to be good even here with the queen on
C1 how is how does that hurt
yeah
just V5
now B5 is going to play I mean there's
this is
I don't I mean
what else is there
coin
D2
keeps tightening the Noose
okay interesting
Queen D2
the staircase and after 192 Knight C4
oh my God my goodness Knight C4 Knight
F4
yeah
but where's the mate
okay what does he want here there's a
win but I don't see it
Knight D3
Ah that's it because if Knight F4 you
just play Knight F4 and mate is
Unstoppable and if Bishop D3 you take
you drag the king out and you Checkmate
it with Bishop D2
oh
what an idea Queen comes to D2 with the
idea of securing the D3 Square for the
Knight
jeez
guys I think he just out thought the
engine right there
okay so we play your cage too
we'll get you here
yeah because you need to make a move
you do need to make a move
and then
or what about this I thought of a crazy
idea
I was thinking of trying to get
something to work like B5 takes takes
two queen E1 but but at the end of the
day remember that yeah white is winning
because the United gets trapped but
these ideas do exist in some of these
positions
Rook H2
I think is a really strong move
basically no other options
what if you
so Rook H2 is white and zuke's mom like
can black walk the King around
effects
all the way to like I don't know
it's E1 or something
you can
now I want to just explain that why is
Rook H2 effective because if black
simply takes yes black wins back the
exchange that Bishop is a crucial
crucial aspect of of the reason that
white is paralyzed now I have four
becomes an issue and white starts to
break free from the chain so this
position isn't about reclaiming the
material it's all about whether white
can break free from
you know from the paralysis
um and and you know
and for the save is gone Queen G2 he has
not gone Rook H2
yeah he is rushing here
but he's trying to put the time pressure
on Magnus Tommy's not a matter here
all right what to do for for Carlson
maybe your key moves looks good
white is totally perilous just Queen G2
Queen she won it's gonna follow for the
rest of Eternity
you know maybe it's yeah Queenie
directory 193 will be his idea
you know what the funny thing is if the
king the black king can't really cross a
six though because the moment it gets to
A6 there's C5 check
so that actually becomes a problem
there's no other way there's no other
pathway
[Music]
I have a feeling black doesn't need that
he doesn't need the support of the king
to conquer the possession
yeah there has to be some sort of a
maneuver but the problem is that okay
maybe use the dark squared Bishop
somehow
I don't see a breakthrough though not
off the top of my head
still looks like the one day B5 should
be the threat right
I agree
and he's about to make a move
what's it going to be
King moved he's gonna move his King
okay he's gonna make some from its
Vladimir is just gonna go Queen G1 Queen
G2 and close his eyes or maybe Rook G1
or power up two one because he got
Knight D3
oh tricky idea
E6 apparently is is possible to open up
the position
that makes sense
G5
H4 not sure
Rook q1 is about to be played
but G5 Rook H1
yeah and you don't want to if that H
fund runs then white is losing
yeah
so maybe Magnus what he wants to do is
just bring the king to C7 so it's far
away from the from the danger and then
play E6 and open the position up
Vladimir has not gone Rook G1 yet he's
hesitating
all right so it's very important to
understand yet again that this isn't
about you know plus two plus three those
black is the only one who can win the
question is is there a concrete plan to
make progress because if there isn't you
know you could play for 50 moves and
nothing's going to change but your idea
Yvonne well eventually G5 could become
possible once the king leaves the
problem is that White's pass spawn could
become dangerous as well
that has to be factored in yes
the passport doesn't mean to anything
but when you're working transferred to
C7 that would be different
yep
yeah G1 played
there's a queen bee to Queen C1 Queen D2
is typical Magnus
because we were looking at something
more concrete more dynamic
he basically just gives the opponent
zero chances and making
the white most uncomfortable setups as
possible
yeah he's he's preserving the pressure
and it's it's crazy how he does that he
he seems to win sometimes and you think
what what does he even do but it's these
Maneuvers that that completely tie his
opponent down
and and that that's vintage Magnus
it's an absolute vintage absolute
vintage Magnus
he's continuing to search for for a plan
we think that I mean it looks like E6
might be the way to go and the idea of
E6 is you want to take on D5
and regardless of the way that white
takes inroads are created the black and
access with his pieces if CD then you
have the B Pawn if Ed
then that black dark light squared
Bishop might come out to F5
been preparing Knight D3
yeah but I just realized the 193 makes
nothing here you can just take some D5
because you never you can never remove
the Knight away because there will be a
chance right
Eon G6
all right
well Magnus can make as many moves as he
wants so it's not an issue he's going to
make time control
um this is not a position where you're
really worried about the clock
unless okay it's complicated
I think he's going to bring his King in
to see he's going to bring his King to
C7 first and then he's gonna start
thinking
yeah because the wife can do anything oh
by the way maybe white should try
something like Queen H1 or G5
mm-hmm
no but then that's losing you're ready
to capture back and taking back the G5
phone
yeah when H1 played
or maybe some luxury Queen G2 waiting
one day to capture the G6 no but there
will be Bishop H3 chuckle
yeah all these lines are this somehow
allow black to infiltrate
yeah I think Max is going to keep
walking his King over
eating the 18 C7
this is a an incredible positional game
so far that exchange sack and the
patience with it with which Magnus is
converted it Queen Ace a queen A2
Magnus has found some incredible moves
in this game but is he going to be able
to put the finishing touches we know how
good he is in converting these positions
he
you know normally I would be doubtful
but when it's in the hands of Magnus
Carlson you just almost expect that he
will find some way
to break through and I would encourage
people to pause for a second and think
about that I mean what that says about
Magnus
yeah definitely starting from this queen
C8 B5 Queen eight Queen A2 and then this
A1 B2 C1 D2
it's just beautiful
and that the patience with which Magnus
has handled this is incredible given you
know at first we thought he might have
been still you know sort of marinating
on yesterday's defeat opening seemed a
little iffy and then you turned just
turned it on at some point which came on
an f-force change sack
you know B5 was an amazing move
E6 has been plugged E6 has been played
and he finds that idea too
and Vladimir's position starting to
crumble at the seams here it seems
wow I mean he's playing like an engine
it's crazy
and this is not an easy position to play
like an engine and I mean like there's a
lot of tempting options
and uh E6 does make a lot of sense of
course because white is so paralyzed
you want to open up the position as much
as possible
yeah because after ed5 of course you
won't take on E6 because then Bishop B6
and oh yeah
this is over I'll see four yeah
but if you allow he takes D5 ct5 that's
simply pushing B Pol and if you take
back with the E Pawn then maybe bishop
F5
yeah and something will have to
materialize her quinnage
I mean amazingly I don't see exactly the
wind here but okay at this point I mean
something has to manifest itself there's
just no way that
that um that there's nothing here
and by this point Magnus will have made
oh no he wouldn't have made the time
control yet but he can make a couple of
waiting moves and then take his 30
minutes to
crack open the position how many moves
well currently they're on move 35 so
Magna says um five moves remaining
including the 40th
yeah
plenty of time
yeah even if you get less than two or
three minutes to just make some key
moves avoid repetition they will be fine
yeah and I mean this does look like an
alpha zero game
yeah
indeed
that shows F5 at the very beginning it's
a great plan
yeah and I think Magnus Robert who's in
the chat
um as much as I hate to acknowledge Him
how terrible commentator is he makes a
good point
which is that people love to crack jokes
at Magnus expense but he's had a
brilliant World Cup he really has
um and the the Magnus always has to deal
with the expectation that he's going to
beat everybody with with every color and
that completely misunderstands the
reality of Chess at the top level where
everybody's amazing and it's it's hard
to beat anybody over 2600.
um you know and definitely over 2700 So
I think people need to appreciate how
consistently is playing how many of
these games he's won and how in most
cases he's able to to take somebody like
Feta Sam who's barely lost the game
himself and immediately
turn it into a one-sided Affair through
His Brilliant place so I really
encourage people to pause for a second
and contemplate that
um and people will have an opportunity
to pause because I think it's time for
us to go on a break
and uh yifon I think
that means that you will be leaving us
for today
yeah unfortunately probably I won't be
able to join you here to see the resort
of this game
no problem we know it's very late and as
always uh it's it's an absolute pleasure
commentating with you fun and uh it
appears that Magnus will drive this home
we will of course have fishy on the
other side of the break but
uh you find it's it's been an honor as
usual and um have a have a great rest of
rest of your night and uh you'll be
joining us I think tomorrow for for game
two of the final so
thank you so much you're fun and um
we will go on a quick break when we come
back we will watch the conclusion of
this beryllium game between Carlson and
fetise with vision okay thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back at the feeder World Cup
once again a great honor to be joined by
Vichy and um some interesting
proceedings today let's quickly for
those for those of you just joining
uh we remind you that kariakin and Duda
made a very quick draw with Sergey
having the white pieces but unable to
create any serious chances against Jan
shistoff's um Vienna variation Vichy
what are your thoughts on this game I
mean they were repeating I think a
previous Duda game until Rook D1 and
yifan and I just weren't that impressed
with this move
was karyakin sort of intending in that
game in that game they played Rook B1
without taking on C6
uh-huh
and I think the difference is if you
play Bishop D7 then I can capture and
play D5 but if I start with 96 then
exactly what Dura did and it's just a
draw I think
right and we were thinking maybe white
we'll take one of the pawns but
yes maybe I think instead of rugby one
Queen C6 check and queen of Queen D7 is
supposed to be equal maybe this is even
around
but I'm uh yeah Queen D7 is very
important not Bishop D7 it's very
awkward yeah but even but
has to be Queen D7 and then we thought
maybe white could play this idea of just
going let's say queen C2 and then some
point Bishop F6 and 94 but probably it's
just nothing
it probably is I mean black has a solid
Square on D6 plus Bishop you can leave
it there and then I mean
it's
ugly but uh an extra Pawn means that
when you recover it it will simplify
right
yeah
just made a mistake in the opening
confused something and uh yeah I don't
really say anything afterwards
um he wasn't on our in our uh commentary
Booth but I'll listen and after the
after the broadcast I really wonder what
because he struggled with black this
tournament I mean especially against Sam
so
you know he's he's out of trouble yes
but I think generally Sergey feels very
confident uh and it's a long tournament
and so maybe even a
Quick Draw is not entirely unwelcome
even though if it's after even though
it's after a rest day but
well yeah another rest day never hurt
anybody
so yeah and the better safe game you
were saying off broadcast sushi that
some odd play by Vladimir at various
important junctures in this game as we
see Carlson well just go back two moves
ago just take one move back for both
sides sure after he's I played E6 here
isn't the position just screaming for
Rook G5 what is wrong with Rook G5 why
didn't he do it
they've got I gotta try to break free
well I guess yes I mean I I just want
the fact that uh Rook on E5 and play
Knight D3 and I think it's my only home
really
really should black contemplate taking
and just taking or is that well then I
think taking Queen H2 here is very
important right I have Queen H2 and
I thought
freeze things up a bit right Queen C1
let's say
yeah
Maybe
[Music]
uh F4 but F4 Knight C4 could be
unpleasant
well maybe it doesn't work tactically
right I mean unless black actually you
know what's going to be magnus's I mean
I assume Vladimir will take with the
epon because cdv5 looks unthinkable
what is going to be white I think Magnus
can play yeah
Bishop A4 Bishop D1 Maybe
uh well we're about to find out okay
we'll find out exactly right
ed5 has happened
and Bishop F5 instantly by Magnus okay
how does white even wait I mean I guess
I would now try to go
I would still go live
oh you would still go Rook G5
well maybe some other way maybe Queen G2
and Rook of Rook G5 but already Queen C1
might just win so
yeah the train has passed it seems yeah
but yeah Rook G5 immediately still
Quincy one but then
well yeah but now I can take take and
[Music]
play Queen F4 and take on the C4 like
that and you're in the main your queen
still has no squares over there now this
Pawn can
bury if Queen G2 can just play H4 it's a
stop Queen G3
patch this is miserable yeah no I I
think it's it's completely lost now
but
um
yeah so Bishop F5 played
and um
there's just no moves
leave paralysis
yeah I don't see one
or Rook G5 might be like the only move
that doesn't
allow some immediate win maybe Queen G1
uh
Magnus has that body language
kind of indicates that he knows
yeah so what if maybe Queen's V1
or exactly is the killer blow here
it's gonna move his Rook
now he's gonna go back to G1 or what yep
yeah I just did
okay so his idea is what Knight G2 Queen
C1 check 91 back or something
right
but Knight G2 there might be
I'd have to be
Knight F3 wow no that I haven't met
before
maybe Knight D3 wins
yes
oh that's curtains yeah so you don't
have Nike to explain
maybe just maybe like king or something
I mean if black plays King E7 d8 C7 A7
a6a B the problem is there A6 is a bit
impassable because of C5 Check Yes I
I can see that but
still
it is a funny idea
well Nigel short is in the house
she might recommend that if that plan
so the question is this where is
what is White's next move if black plays
King E8 or something
yeah but
then does Queen C1 work
so let's say here here okay it's one
king F7
same
concept
yeah Rook G3 might be Bots because if
Queen G2 then you
then then Queen C1
I don't know in H1
maybe white should play Queen G2
93 isn't it over
oh
thanks yep
I agree
it is
that you have to go Rook G3
yes
it's been played and now Queen C1
King G2
you could even play Queen C1 and Bishop
D2
forget the Rook I'm going through no
then I'll play F4 right
um
so here here here
and then you have this nasty oh yeah
that is a very nasty move
so I guess why it shouldn't black
shouldn't move the bishop away
no
actually once again white doesn't have a
mole
another little bit King F1 uh and G2 F1
G2 why that's not a new way to repeat
but King F1 then Bishop B2 maybe no I
thought after Queen D2 but uh you're
right it's black sits if black white
still doesn't have a move because if we
go Queen F1 then I can go Queen D2 and
lock you in
and that's a that's a just a lock
thank you
yeah he can move the king to a couple
pitiful King moves and then go Knight G2
and slowly
but like Harry when black might be able
to play G5 hit G5 H4 if he wants here
for instance
right
yeah so Magnus
has two moves until the time control
Knight D7
so you're going to D4
why not
yeah first class plane ticket to decor
and
does white have anything to put in
Black's way
wow
yeah tough
maybe you should try Knight sheet too
but then check in Bishop D2 and I win
the pace right oh yeah
yeah this is this is over I think that's
it
even G4 might be possible briefly
all right but take take Bishop B1
unfortunately otherwise it's almost half
works but
yeah this is a
do you think white was better out of the
opening and then
to the staff started going yesterday
when Magnus played King at seven
threatening The Rook on F4
are not threatening but threatening to
exactly Exchange
incident might be one it occurred to me
that he could play Rook G1
checked this I noticed it uh just very
fast and I wanted to go Rook G1 here
because the big is the question why
Magnus didn't sack the exchange your
move earlier but that's another story
but now if you take take and go Bishop
at six I'll play Rook G5 and I want to
move my queen and play F4
isn't that half decent
that's a cool idea for kind of a
prophylactic idea against the exchange
yes well then the question arises why
did Magnus not take one move ago with
the Rook on H1
yeah I mean he might have wanted
something like B5 simultaneously
okay but then now I can uh can I take on
E5 and go Queen G5 no you have Rook F6
and play and nothing's going on as far
as
I could still improve with um
foreign
ID one now
yes
essential name but then Rook C8 I mean
I felt like this Rook A3 move but I
thought I'd say it was a it made sense
but I don't know
maybe it allowed too much activity
yeah a lot of them are thinking after
Knight D7
I mean this H form of has been
of taking the World by storm in many
different types of positions
work G5
it's about time
well then you should have done it five
months ago
a day a dollar what's the expression day
late and a dollar short the other way
around
so
okay
how does black handle that
40.
I guess the question is should black
take that because Rook takes F5 is an
idea
that's a serious threat of course
well I could go Bishop B1 then you'll go
Queen H3 and I think you might be
Breaking Free
because if I go Knight C5 we have Queen
C8 and just about in time though
to create some contact line
[Music]
I mean even that looks bad but um
because I can play Bishop G5 hit G5
Bishop F5 back that's not going to be
nice
but it doesn't seem in magnus's style
too
to allow
whoops yeah
so move 40 for black and he's got
seven and a half minutes
yeah rep G5 is definitely better late
than never
but
but a few months ago it was
I mean not for an advantage but it did
solved a lot of problems when if he had
done it with the tension still there
because he would have had this F4 break
as well maybe and so on now it's after
85 85 there's no Force left in F4
right Magnus is captured
then one idea is to continue with the
maneuver Knight C5
Knight b394.
yeah Queen H2 King E7 right
and then maybe F4 should be played
nonetheless but then I go Knight B3
and then you're going Queen G3 and
trying to crawl up
okay yep
in fact the queen A3 by now is check
right with the King on seven so Knight
C5 we're looking at Queen H2
that's in a bit of an annoying move
could you go night it might be three
Queen D6 Bishop H3
oh yeah that is winning so I think it
might be what am I missing
bars
well maybe Queen D6 anyway Bishop H3
King G1
takes King H2 and hope for a perpetual
that might occur because Shaq and queen
she's or even if if white ends up down a
piece but with a lot of these pawns it's
going to be exactly Queen F6 takes G6
and put it back somewhere and uh throw
in G6 you might just about create kick
up enough dust
right
yeah
it can be annoying in these positions
just all this small little counter
playing
so what else exists here
what's the move number by the way
uh 41 so both both players have made
time control
so conceivably Magnus could take
and in eternity here it's a
figure out the most precise continuation
I guess Queen takes G5 should be
considered but it just doesn't seem like
it seems like it let's swipe prolong the
game Queen H2
I'm not sure it's probably the best move
it's probably what the computers would
do but
you know when you've got someone unable
to move then you like to tighten the
nose not to release it
right
there is also I don't know
gosh so this line let me just show it on
the board Queen H2 King E7
and somehow F4
this still has to be winning though
maybe Knight D3 is just over the queen
ending is one
so I have to take
yeah take
Queen D3 check
let's see here G1 G2
and you take
yeah I have to because if I go 21k H2
then I have not gained anything but
let's say queen takes there
and now if you play F5 I have Queen C1
takes G5 takes F5 ah even better yeah
even both so you'll go Queen H3
I go Queen takes D5 you go Queen C8
maybe this is already quite a bit of
counter play it's annoying
yeah no Bishop didn't make the three
looks bad that's okay
but somehow it's not okay moves have
been played at night E5 I think actually
E5
huh
that's interesting
but now if I go Queen H4 what does he
want exactly that was what I was
thinking
maybe he goes back to C1 now he goes
Queen C1 sorry
oh hi now Knight D3 becomes a threat but
then Queen D AP Bishop H3 has to be not
forgotten about
I'm gonna wait for it to update and then
we're going to analyze on the board so
played by Magnus
all right so
oops
in H4
I mean C1
yeah no moves
we go here and there's Bishop H3
yeah
and if they go up four then there is
then Knight D3 wins uh material
are just Knight of four yeah or this
yeah
so is it over or does white have
anything other than Queen H4
no it's over it's the only question is
is there any try any single trap left
yes
clearly the evaluation is
not in doubt anymore I mean if you throw
the pawn well I could even take it and
then you lose everything at this point
I mean queen F4 and then the end game is
winning right
the white still has no moves
Bishop takes station that's nothing
yeah we might see resignation also
yes imagine it's disgusting to play this
against Magnus After Time control
you're suffering
I was wondering I mean maybe that you
can
call me out on just this is bunk but I
think players tolerance for suffering in
bad positions is not only has defensive
skill improved objectively but players
are more willing I think to to suffer
through long defensive task whereas
earlier it just seemed like there was a
little bit less tolerance of that
um in general not to try to accuse you
know
older players of
players from past generations of
not having the tenacity but
do you think there's something something
psychological about the the Improvement
in defensive skill at the top level
there are many many areas where the
computers influenced our thinking and uh
hanging on for dear life is one of them
I mean you realize that even positions
which are lost still have a little bit
of life left in them
and I think it's one of the reasons you
don't understand
there were a few people who never
resigned even earlier
but
that was just stubbornness I think
whereas now
this idea of just
forcing asking your opponent to prove it
I mean dead last positions nobody wants
to thrash on but
in some in some position like this
a mistake and you could get a perp so
this is I think uh you have the right to
hope for a miracle
um
yeah that's the sense I get is
everybody's looking looking looking
in almost any position for for the
tiniest sliver of opportunity
also you're discussing the real position
but if you have only one move each time
then you might as well make it and see
what happens right
nothing nothing to lose at that point
paradoxically
Magnus seems like he has the face of
someone who's got it all figured out
which he has of course
it's not too much to figure out anymore
yeah it's he managed to motivate himself
for the game today
we had the impression at first he was a
little bit
disconcerted but
somehow he got it together you know once
once he started once he sacked The
Exchange and then a brilliant
sequence afterward
and I was also wondering if you think
fedesaf
is he just is he more disappointed that
he doesn't make the candidates or do you
think he's happy at the opportunity to
play Magnus which one outweighs
yeah what was this
I can't believe
uh
playing Magnus it doesn't compare to the
candidates because the candidates is way
more important
right I mean you can make some sort of
cancellation out of this but of course
you take the candidates not that he
would
he would have to beat kariaken but the
way he lost must have been disappointing
for him and I think
he probably hasn't gotten over the
disappointment either
because he had a very good tournament up
until that point and then it's it's
always very sad when you throw
everything away you know you've played a
good tournament everything and then one
day the whole thing
just goes away so he must be very
disappointed and if you think about it
yeah two losses can including today and
tomorrow if Magnus wins it'll be three
losses to end the tournament
and that's sort of what you what you
focus on is the way the tournament ends
you can play an amazing tournament in
losing the last round and that's all you
think about
my personal experiences sometimes I'll
be minus two or something and I'll win
the last round game and I'll leave the
tournament in a good mood or
I'll be plus two and I'll lose the last
round game and I'll go in an awful mode
even though right I'm a whole point
higher than in the other version so I
think emotionally uh how you sign off is
much more important than what your total
score is
right and then the flight back is
entirely dependent on
yeah
um
or the closing sir your your face in the
closing ceremony you're mood in the
closing ceremony
so
um
yeah and I I get the sense that Vladimir
might think for a while and just give up
all my talk of
not resigning but this one just seems
on the other hand he might make a few
more moves as well I mean once you've
stayed this long you might as well
I don't know that is no fun way of going
out so let's put it right bye
right
yeah four
wow
yeah this line of H4 will probably enter
the mainstream though
it seems like black is not just the
mainstream right now actually there's so
many guys that throw it in no maybe it's
uh almost it dominates and rapid and
Blitz rather than the
classical just yet
right but Sam beats Fiddler with it
earlier yes
and they're playing H4 earlier and
earlier these days
and he stopped the clock yes and he's
resigning
and that's totally understandable the
game is just over
and Magnus Carlson defeats Vladimir
fedasev
with the black pieces in game one of the
third place match an amazing positional
Game Exchange sacrifice
this will be analyzed and
and reviewed in videos this was a
vintage Magnus game
as he defeats fedesev who of course is
still suffering from the disappointment
of not making the candidates
what a game by the world champion
he's still not going to be happy that
he's not playing for first place but
this is rating wise especially rating
wise he might even be happier if he
defeats feta save twice
he gets some points back but uh it's
interesting that in In classical chess
his lead is now so big I mean Fabi has
dropped off and he was the only real
Contender for uh the ray of number one
rating that
it was a cheeky comment but uh it struck
me that he might actually be more
interested in his Blitz rating now than
in his classical rating
right yeah it's classical same way that
I think the World Cup matters more to
him now than the world champion World
Championship yeah it's what he doesn't
have but
um
but Magnus does seem to be indicating
that uh instead of going back to G1 and
snuffing out his hopes of castling
because he never got to disentangle that
the federacyf could have castled at one
point
um
[Music]
basically even allowing Bishop H3 and
Bishop takes F1 it was worth doing just
to
liberate your pieces because you might
still have enough equality
yeah this was the moment where and I
think Yvonne indicated this queen H1 and
and despite appearances this idea of
Knight g2l4
um it makes it very hard for black to
preserve the bind and yeah and and uh I
think that I say I've probably ruled
this out instinctively just because he
saw Bishop H3 shows the importance of
not stopping your calculation
prematurely of course easy for me to say
yeah I'm very good at driving a car from
the back seat
and um
as they analyze the game concludes
and rumors of magnus's
downfall or slump are greatly
exaggerated as per usual
I think he's well that's the thing I
mean he Magnus has an excellent
tournament
it's just
uh when Magnus does it they say it's a
failure but almost anyone else would
take his tournament with both hands
well yeah there's always this actually
there's one it's only this one rapid and
uh one minus lump
uh right
duda's achievement is phenomenal
nonetheless I mean he helped Magnus both
games and then uh it was never really
worse in the match and that was that's
important
yeah that's absolutely true and uh as
they continue analyzing the game we're
gonna go on a break when we come back we
are going to wrap up today's coverage of
the finals we had a very interesting
Affair between magnets and fedexv we're
going to draw some concluding thoughts
when we come back don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Worlds Cup is in the books game one of
the finals as concluded we had a quick
drop in our first place match between
Sergey karyakin and yanashest abdura
with Duda again showing excellent
confidence in the opening preparation
and Sergey potentially confusing
something but a quick draw is the
results and Magnus Carlson defeating
fedes with black in the third place
matchup as we check out the bracket we
see how many amazing players have been
knocked out
how far yancha stop Duda has gone uh to
be in the place that he is and of course
game two of the finals will be tomorrow
at the usual time 8 A.M Eastern Time 5
a.m Pacific followed by the tie break if
necessary for either of the match-ups
and Vichy it's interesting that it's
only two games for the finals this time
I think it's a reasonable Amendment
um what do you think do you think that's
that's a good rule change because
normally of course the finals are four
games
yes
um you can't suddenly change the final
and make it four I don't see the point
and um
on top of that this year the tournament
was extra long because they added more
participants at the beginning
so it seems like a fair decision
yeah I think the players are definitely
at the end of their ropes we can see
that Dura and kariakin will definitely
need an another rest day and uh
what a day it was an incredible game by
Magnus but the time has has come for us
to wrap up and uh as per usual first I'd
like to thank
um the entire audience we had as usual
tens of thousands watching across the
platforms this would not be possible
without everybody's viewership and
support and skipping meetings to watch
the game not just
not just never be in support of that but
a big thank you to everybody watching to
our incredible production team and Bick
who works very very hard to make sure
everything runs so smoothly and of
course
and Bishi I know you joined toward the
end of the rounds uh this time around
but nonetheless it's a great honor and I
know we all very much appreciate your
insights so thank you vishy and we will
have you again tomorrow
hopefully we'll have an interesting
Affair between Duda uh between Duda and
karyakan
all right well thank you to everybody
um another day in the books at the
World's Cup finals game two tomorrow at
8 A.M we will see you then goodbye for
now
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]